[Music]
thank you
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
foreign
state
[Music]
it's always projection with them the
Deep State the Deep State the Deep state
oh Durham and Bill Barr
Donald Trump are the swamp they are the
Deep State yeah we knew that
but this reporting yesterday of the
investigation
of Durham
to find the corruption in in the 2016
Russian collusion to prove that Hillary
Clinton was the one who colluded with
Russia only under uncovered
crimes that Trump had committed and of
course of course in true swampy deep
State fashion
Bill Barr covers it up
now he's going to be out on his circuit
selling his book
and the media is gonna let him let him
come over and lie to him on camera and
say no no see you're misinterpreting the
facts
the reason why I did this is because of
blah blah blah yakety schmackity more
lies more Santos type [__] listen
folks I've been telling you this for a
long time since since we knew about
George Santos he came on this National
scene of being the Liars of all the
Liars of the Liars he's not
he's just a republican he's he is just a
[__] Republican
they don't give a [__]
about the truth
one of the reasons why
is because their entire party has been
taken over by people with no conscience
whatsoever you think Bill Barr has even
just a hint a drip a shred of conscience
get the [__] out of here with that
nonsense Donald Trump Durham may have at
one time but he does not anymore all the
people out there are like oh well I
respect Durham Durham's a great
prosecutor I don't care who you are I
don't give a [__] if you're on the left
to the right you're respected you're not
anymore your opinion doesn't [__]
matter Durham was with Trump they was
with Barr when you [__] get in bed
with these dogs you get fleas
that's how it is
that's how it's going to be with this
party they do not have any principle
anymore there is no conscience in their
party
you look at the Speaker of the House
Kevin McCarthy look look to him for some
conscience no not a shred of it maybe at
one point but they had to sell it away
they have to sell it away why do you
think people like [__] Matt gants
Marjorie Taylor Greene Lauren bobert Jim
Jordan Paul gozar Andy Biggs Josh Hawley
Ted Cruz Mitch McConnell why do you
think these [__] scumbags are driving
their party
they don't have a conscience have you
heard the name Mitt Romney lately no you
haven't
you won't
now I'm not I'm not I'm not advocating
for Mitt Romney here
but at least Mitt Romney at least Mitt
Romney almost reaches
that that low bar of a decent human
being with a conscience always almost
there
but that is way too much way too much
for the Deep State swamp America First
Nazi party that the Republicans are
and we're and we're not supposed to be
pissed
hell rewind the clock a little further
did you know Mitt Romney was their
Presidential nominee Mitt Romney was
their Presidential nominee
his running mate Paul Ryan not welcome
in politics anymore because he used to
have a conscience and he didn't sell it
all the way out I mean again I have a
cutting for Paul Ryan
but when they they can't stand and and
say out loud that Trump's the greatest
president of all time when they can't
say that out loud
they have not reached the the level of
sellout to the Deep State swamp that is
the America First Nazi party
they have not reached that level yet
so Paul Ryan gone Mitt Romney gone Jesus
Christ they still [__] on John McCain's
grave
because the man ultimately had just a
shred just he just reached that [__]
bar that man it's hard for Republicans
to reach but he got there in the decency
and conscience level you remember the
moment
of John McCain correcting some some
elderly lady who was deluded by Fox News
thinking that Barack Obama was some sort
of scary scary Muslim as if Muslims are
scary in the first place as if we can't
in this country have a Muslim president
or a president who grew up as a Muslim
what in the [__] is wrong with you
people
as if that inherently makes you [__]
scary but he had a scary name and he had
the scary skin color
and a scary religion
and John McCain said no he's not a he's
not a terrorist he's not
he reached the bark I mean it's a low
bar but it's high for [__] them they
reach
but he ultimately picked Sarah Palin
who we know
was not born with the conscience I mean
maybe she was but
it would be hard for her to prove that
don't you think
that [__] scumbag
and John McCain picked her why do you
think why do you think Barack Obama
became for present in the first place he
had a message he had a national
narrative he was a transformative figure
but ultimately John McCain sold out his
conscience
foreign by picking her
and at the time in 2008 part of the
country was like yeah you know
we just need people who reach the bar of
decency right like I'm okay with my
politicians being a little corrupt but
God damn
and on and on it went and further and
further down this [__] trash Heap we
got
which delivered us the technicality win
of Donald Trump which put him in power
for four [__] years the ability to
destroy our [__] institutions our
institutions it's our government it is
[__] ours it's not big government or
small government or scary government
our corrupt government It Is Us
do not let them steal that away from us
they they do it every [__] day
they try to steal away our [__]
sovereignty of our government
the government is us it's the people God
damn it
and they steal it away
and he stole it away for four [__]
years
and he keeps stealing it away by mind
[__] his cult members
foreign
but they're not going to stop like if
you
if you think these people
who have no decency no conscience
they they have no Humanity built inside
and operate on just a simple level
of decent Humanity
if you think those people are gonna stop
now they're just gonna be like you know
what ah
oh man liberal democracy wins gosh darn
it
no
they're hell-bent
on destroying the thing that is their
enemy and it's the truth it's democracy
and it's you the people
and it's your voice that is what is
their enemy
and that is why Donald Trump directed
Bill Barr and Bill Barr directed Durham
to kill your voice because your voice
said in 2016 even if he wins on a
technicality Hillary Clinton still won
by three million votes the country
wanted her
foreign
they can't have that kind of [__]
truth they can't have that kind of
[__] truth
so much so that they're willing to go on
a Witch Hunt and charge people with
fraudulent [__] prosecutions
all the while finding legitimate crimes
that the guy who directed the [__]
investigation was committing
and then and in true deep State swampy
fashion
these these [__] vile pieces of [__]
make sure to cover that [__] up
and we wonder why so many people are
[__] pissed off in this country
look we're not [__] divided down the
middle this is this is [__] that
we're somehow 50 50 get the [__] out of
here with that nonsense
half the country is not part of the cult
it's just heavily concentrated in areas
and really honestly I've been talking
about it for several months especially
after the midterms the 2022 midterms
is it's all about affiliation in the
first place
they don't [__] know their their head
from their ass let alone what the truth
is
in these circles where they don't have
opinions they have beliefs
that's right I said it your opinion on
guns isn't an opinion it's a belief your
opinion
on the lgbtq community is not an opinion
it's belief
opinions are based in fact
and you do not get to come to the
negotiating table with us the people the
government with your beliefs
you have to form some sort of an opinion
based on fact
not just what your feely Fields tell you
oh man I I get really weirded out and I
feel really weird when I know that
there's gay people
and I'm a snowflake and I can't handle
other people's who they love so I'm
gonna say that it's my opinion that they
shouldn't they shouldn't have rights
that's not an opinion that's your belief
built inside a delusional mind [__]
alternate reality that has no basis in
fact and you [__] who has a
belief not an opinion until you form an
opinion based on fact you do not you do
not get to negotiate how our society
sets policy Rhonda santis you
[__]
canceling
College Prep African-American studies in
the State of Florida an elective course
for dual credit for advanced education
for people who want to know the truth
who are seeking the truth through
education which is the purpose of
[__] learning and education in the
first place and they can't have that
they gotta cancel it
cancel culture
foreign am I pissed off this morning you
goddamn right I'm pissed off in the
country I'm telling you the country is
going to be really pissed off
uh this tape
of these five police officers
who have been charged in the murder
of Tyree Nichols in Memphis that's going
to be released
um there's an interview with Don Lemon
in the chief of police in Memphis
and she's basically bracing the country
that
if you thought
the George Floyd murder tape where's
jeric Chauvin showed no [__] no
[__] Humanity strip George Floyd of
all
all of his humanity and killed him
murdered him in front of people and
cameras because he knew he could
if that sickens you you're wait
this is supposed to be
foreign
video and it's going to be all over the
internet
and you know my view of it and a lot of
people are going to say don't look at it
don't watch it and I know the family
doesn't want you to watch it
and people are going to be marching in
the streets over this I have a feeling
buddy do I have a feeling and there's
going to be [__] fake ass agitators
out there trying to make protesters
who are trying to keep black people and
people of color especially black men in
this country safe from law enforcement
murdering them I don't give a [__] what
what race what religion how long what
community the police officers from
the entire institution of law
enforcement in this country is built the
foundation is white supremacy
and if you don't know that if you if you
don't know that if you don't know that
then then you're part of the cult
you're part of the [__] cult
are there good cops out there few and
far between
they got they they got a high bar to
reach to get there for God damn sure
and the right wing media is going to use
the race of these five officers because
all these officers are black men
that oh well see it's not white people
killing white cops killing black young
black men who gives a [__] who's
murdering them and what race they are
they got the [__] badge on
don't you understand
we we've been through this time and time
again you [__] turned
Colin Kaepernick's protest into a
protest of the flag in the military
when it's exactly this murder of Tyree
Nichols
that Colin Kaepernick
was protesting
Colin Kaepernick wasn't taking a knee
against white people he was taking a
knee against the authoritarian law
enforcement agencies in this country the
entire institution of law enforcement
that is based in the foundation of white
supremacy
and racist institutions it doesn't
[__] matter what the officer's name
is what their race is what their
background is the community that they
come from that's the whole point
it's the institution you dumb
[__] and that's why he was
kneeling
no justice no peace Jesus Christ we just
had Martin Luther King Day
and on this show I told you I told you
that morning I was working out listening
to the Birmingham Jail letter
that Martin Luther King Jr
recorded reading that letter that he
wrote in that jail
and I realized in the moment
listening to him
listening to the words that Dr Martin
Luther King wrote no justice no peace
and what it meant
and I realized that my entire life
my entire life growing up in rural White
America they used MLK they used Dr
Martin Luther King Jr to sanitize his
image
to sanitize his message because his
message
was for you white people out there
who stand back and stand by because you
just don't wanna you just don't want to
talk about the issue
you may not be racist
you may not it's just uncomfortable for
you to talk about race
go read that Birmingham
Jail letter from Dr Martin Luther King
Jr
it's going to be vitally important
in the coming days in the coming weeks
as this video
of Tyree Nichols being murdered
beaten to death by five police officers
it doesn't matter who is behind the
badge folks
the badge is what the representation is
they're murdering murdering
black men young black men
we watched it with George Floyd and
we're gonna see it again
and you should watch it I know you don't
want to
I know the family probably doesn't want
you to see it there's a lot of people
not going to want to watch it
no justice no peace
and if you seek Peace by not watching
what happened to Tyree Nichols because I
haven't seen it
but I'm gonna watch every [__] second
of it over and over and over again
I will not be peaceful on this video I
will not look away
and the country shouldn't either
and it's going to be hard to watch it
it's not going to be easy
it won't be easy
not for individuals not for groups
not for the country
and it's going to sicken you
the commentary that's going to come from
the right
that they're going to use to demonize
Tyree Nichols they're gonna pause it
they're gonna zoom in
they're gonna nitpick the video to death
of why he deserved to be murdered
they're gonna do it they're gonna
[__] do it and they're gonna do the
whole well these are five black police
officers it doesn't [__] matter
no justice no peace
and the country should not be peaceful
as this video is released
you shouldn't just be comfortable into
not watching it
we need to get uncomfortable
and I'm I'm talking about you white
people you
you need to get [__] uncomfortable
really uncomfortable
and you need you need to seek that
uncomfort
and talk
to people of color
talk to them but not just talk at them
listen to them about their experience
listen to Why
Tyree Nichols life [__] mattered
open your [__] ears
open your brains
give Tyree Nichols Justice
not just in the court system because
it's going to be a long time
it's going to be a long hard battle
for these five police officers who
murdered Tyra Nichols
but give them Justice
by lending your ear and listening to
their experience and Tyree Nichols
experience there's a video going around
of Tyree Nichols skateboarding
and I'm sure it's heartbreaking for the
family that
they don't have the ability to gain any
more memories of Tyree Nichols
on that skateboard
but their families out there today
that will suffer the same fate
if we just want to be comfortable if we
just look we just want to have peace we
don't want to have this conversation
it's a tough conversation to have to
talk about our institutional racism in
this country no it's not it is not a
difficult conversation because all you
have to do is listen
just listen
you're just damn lucky
that they don't want revenge they love
this country
listen
people of color in this country are the
most patriotic that there are
they love this country they fight for
this [__] country they serve this
country
and so many forms and Fashions the
military
public service
they get up every [__] morning to
their nine to five jobs
in some of their broken communities
and they work their asses off
to make something of themselves in this
country to make something for their
family in this country
you don't think that service to us as a
society
well then you're lost
I don't fear the no peace
but be vigilant
because there will be lies and there
will be misinformation out there and we
have to smash it with the truth
and every single moment when this tape
is released
we have to smash it with the truth
just remember as this tape is released
I'm telling you
go listen and read
Dr King's letter from the Birmingham
Jail
if you are white
and you believe that black lives matter
and you believe in equity and equality
and you want to use your right white
privilege to smash and kill White
Privilege in this country once and for
all it's going to take a lot of work it
ain't gonna happen overnight
foreign
go read that letter from Dr King
you'll know what no justice no peace
means
listen to his words
listen to their words listen to their
experience
and let's do justice
to not just Tyree Nichols
but to the hundreds
of people of color who were murdered
by the the racist institution of law
enforcement in this country
let's do them Justice
maybe the families will have peace
everyone stick around we'll be right
back right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
the uh popular
I don't know if we'll have time to watch
it today or not
we got the bone-in of the week it is
Friday
the second hour of the show we will have
bonehead of the week
so we'll see if we can get to
um the Paul Pelosi video again I'm not
sure if we will we will get there now I
know people are are saying it in the
chat that this tape was released
um and and I've I've got I've got it if
um
um I I got the I got the links and stuff
but I don't know if we'll get to it
today or not we do have bonehead of the
week
um and there's a few things that I do
want to get to before that so we may or
may not get to that videotape and
there's going to be a lot of videotape
being talked about today I guess
um so we'll see if
now what comes out of the
the videotape
um
someone's asking on on Twitch is this
live well now you know
yeah it's live subscribe or like us
follow us whatever the hell it is it's
free
it's free and everyone is speaking of
that I want to thank everyone who has
gone over to patreon and supported me on
patreon it's it's been a oh this is
great I can't believe the support just
by mentioning it a few times here on the
show uh you know we don't get we don't
actually get paid by George Soros it's a
joke we make we don't actually get some
sort of [__] liberal George Soros
Kamal chick it's not a thing that we get
um you know and I don't get the antifa
payment that I joke about here it's so
we are Independent Media
and this does take time and it does take
away from I don't know other money
making Ventures so if you can show
support that's great and you guys have
with patreon
um it's it's been fantastic uh I haven't
done patreon
um
for numerous reasons but I should have
done it months and months ago because
more than anything it just gives you
guys the ability to support the show so
if you go to patreon there's there's
four levels but there's three that are
serious the other one's kind of a joke
um but uh of course I can't can't do
anything without you know kidding around
a bit but here's the thing is that for
five dollars you just your general
support you know that that's wonderful
and a lot of people had done just
general support because you know the
show is free like it's free for you to
watch and I don't gate any of the
content I I at this point I don't have
plans to gate the show I want this
two-hour show I want it to be three
hours really and I want it to be ungated
forever I want you to be able to listen
to this show for free for as long as I'm
doing it I don't wanna I don't want you
to have to pay to get this show
so the five dollars is just for General
support if you come here every day and
you're listening and you enjoy the
content and you want us to keep doing it
keep producing it it's just general
support the second level of ten dollars
you actually get a special promo code
for the for the merch store at D Tony
michaels.com the Tony michaels.com the
merch store there so you get a and you
can also find the patreon link at the
Tony michaels.com or you can go to
patreon slash the Tony Michaels the
moderators or surely have put it in the
um the the chat already but just just
just go to the attorney michaels.com you
can find the merch store there and the
patreon but the third level is twenty
dollars and you get that you get all the
stuff you get in the first level your
general support you get the promo code
for the merch but you also get a shout
out I'm trying to figure out exactly how
I want to do this shout out
um so I'm trying to figure that out I I
I and I gotta figure it out pretty damn
quick because I get I've got a lot of I
got a lot of people building up here
that I got to do a shout out to so but I
do want to give a collective shout out
to everyone I want to thank you because
you are the best audience in the world
truly you are you come here every day it
keeps getting bigger and bigger and
wider and wider audience across
platforms we're trying to get to 20 000
on YouTube so that would be another
favor I asked is come over and subscribe
on YouTube even if you're listening
somewhere else whether you're
downloading it on Apple Spotify Google
on the audio version you're watching it
on Twitter at Tony Michaels pod or if
you're watching it on Midas Touch
Facebook page or my Facebook page at the
Tony Michaels or you're on Twitch right
now it is live it is live
if you're on Twitch
um just come over to the YouTube channel
and do me that favor just go over
subscribe and and share it share it with
everyone on every platform whatever
platform people want to watch it on
share the show we've got to get the
message out we've got to get the
narrative down we have to do this it is
crucial uh that's how we're gonna beat
the deep [__] State um
swamp
well that is trumpism the America First
Nazi party the party who has no
conscience
at all
at all they have none yeah they'll prove
it out this weekend oh my god with this
Paul Pelosi tape and people are saying
it's bad
um I I don't know
I haven't seen that tape yet either but
I'm sure it's horrible but it's probably
worse than you can imagine this Paul
Pelosi tape and with this [__] Q Anon
Maga assassination nut breaking into
Nancy Pelosi's house and
trying to kill her and Paul Pelosi
because he's mind [__] by Facebook
mind [__] by the horse-paced group on
Facebook or Donald Trump himself
these Q Anon nuts it's a q Anon World
we're just living in it folks and it's
[__] crazy
we are at the intersection of
WrestleMania in real life as I say
and I'm sure this Paul Pelosi video is
going to bring light to that but they're
gonna be scumbags these America First
Nazis are gonna oh boy they're gonna
this tape is only gonna spend more
conspiracy theories that are going to be
obviously [__] [__]
obvious [__] [__] we watched
yesterday the Cheeto dust Q100 himself
in a five-minute rant about how he's
guilty and projecting his guilt on
everyone else
and now we know why he did that
yesterday with the 2016 collusion
because he knew the news was gonna drop
that that he committed crimes in Italy
and that's the only crimes that Durham
could find as crimes he committed
no [__] Sherlock this is not difficult
it's easier than a DOT to dot a b c d
it's easier than that it's very easy to
see
hell boy it's Friday bonehead of the
week do you guys know bone and the week
I know there's some new audience members
here probably who haven't been here with
us on Friday every single Friday here's
what we do
we have a segment called bonehead of the
week we put the poll out the night
before and you vote you decide for
bonehead of the week
and then on Friday me and my co-host
Gabe Sanchez break it down right now he
is working on the graphics
so that's why on Friday uh you know
because normally it's the first 30
minutes I do my little a black I do my
rant and sometimes I get off on a
tangent sometimes uh every no every
single time if you've been here more
than once you know that oh I could I
could probably do three hours of that
I I I I'm
maybe two and a half
um I could just keep railing on these
son of a [__]
I get [__] pissed I get pissed off
when I when I watch what they've done to
our government
to our democracy to our sovereign
country and what they want to do with it
Jesus Christ
they give a battalion of Tanks
to Ukraine we make sure that Ukraine has
a battalion 31 tanks which in the grand
scheme of things is it going to help
Ukraine absolutely do they need them
[__] for sure
It's Gonna Save probably hundreds if not
thousands of civilians lives in Ukraine
by Smashing up the the Russian army
the murderous dictator Vladimir Putin
it's been almost a year now he was
supposed to win this in like three hours
you remember that he's just gonna March
in and Ukraine's gonna be like oh yeah
you have [__] you're here we might as
well give it up to you
and Vladimir Putin that murderous
[__] dictator Trump's buddy
the person he colluded with that John
Durham
use the deep [__] State swamp to try to
project
Trump's collusion to Hillary and it was
unsuccessful because it wasn't true just
not how it happens normally
that [__]
almost a year ago decided to try to
steal away the sovereignty of Ukraine's
democracy
and he thought they were just going to
be like oh yeah sure [__] democracy we
want a dictator that's what we want and
they didn't
he begged here's here was Putin's bet
really
he was like ah these people think
they're democracy's corrupt and and
democracy is not worth fighting for
because it is corrupt
so they'll come over to the dark side
that's what he thought he thought they'd
just lay down
they thought zelinski would pack his
[__] and leave
that that he was like man that [__]
ain't worth fighting for
he figured zielinski's uh campaign
against the corruption inside of their
democracy wasn't real
that he wouldn't fight for the Democracy
that he that he
promise to uncorrupt in his presidential
campaign
he was wrong he was dead wrong there's a
[__] reason for that folks
Liberty is a hell of a drug
even just the thought the hope of
Liberty is a hell of a drug it's a hell
of a drug
it bans people together
it gets them to fight United
that's what it does
and there's Clips out of Russia
that shows what happens to a population
when it's under authoritarian Rule and
they have no control no control over the
authoritarian people in Russia are
[__] besides themselves
they can't believe it's been over a year
they were told ah [__] Ukraine wants to
be part of Russia
and the Russian army is getting [__]
crushed the world is standing behind
democracy
as a collective as a whole the liberal
democracies of the world are standing
behind democracy who thought that would
happen
Putin didn't count on that
and that's because authoritarians
believe not the net opinion it's not an
opinion based in fact it's their belief
it's their stupid delusional mind [__]
belief
that Liberals are weak and liberal
democracy is weak they're [__] dumb
I've been telling you this for months
and months and months that liberalism is
not weak liberals aren't [__] weak
are there liberals that are snowflakes
sure
sure there are of course
we've got them too
but to act like the foundation of
liberalism is weak you're a dumb
[__]
again you just need to go look up the
word in the dictionary read the
definition
read it out loud maybe maybe read it to
yourself in the mirror I don't know that
might be a good exercise
may you know what have someone else read
you the definition after you have read
it quietly read it out loud and then
read it in the mirror to yourself
they'd have someone else read it to you
then you might get a second opinion of
someone else of how they would read it
and maybe they'll read it to you and
then maybe just meant just maybe just
maybe you will understand that the
foundation of liberalism is freedom
maybe maybe you'll understand that
if you do that exercise
and understanding what I don't know a
word means
and if you still
implant the definition of liberal or
liberalism small L [__] I'm not
talking about large L I'm I am a capital
l liberal I consider myself liberal I'm
proud to be a [__] liberal I will
always be proud to be a [__] liberal
and you should be too but if you're not
and whatever
sure that that's your Liberty to not
identify as a liberal it's just funny
that liberal democracy delivers you that
right and that freedom to have your
belief
of what you are and how you identify I'm
fine with that I'm cool with that to be
to be frank whatever whatever the [__]
you want to be or whatever you think you
are or you think you want to be good for
you you you just don't get to press your
beliefs and have your beliefs suppress
everyone else's rights
it's not a thing because that's not
Liberty
and rather you like it or not
the foundation of Liberty or liberalism
is Liberty
and liberal democracy does not put up
with authoritarianism why do you think
the entire liberal world is behind
Ukraine is because they stood and fought
for their liberalism for their Liberty
for their freedom for their sovereignty
against an authoritarian
a murderous [__] dick a war criminal
he's killing civilians
in his quest to not take Ukraine because
he's not he's not having a lot of
success it's been a year and he was
supposed to have
it done in three minutes or three hours
or three days whatever the [__] he said
whatever his promise was to the Russian
people
whatever it was which it's all lies and
it continues to be lies and frankly
Russia is getting very frustrated the
problem the problem the problem is is
Russia is not a democracy see and when
you don't have democracy you can't get
rid of an authoritarian leader you can't
get rid of them well I mean you can
you know maybe they eat an ammo sandwich
I don't know or something else happens
you know sometimes there's ways around
it
but generally speaking your
authoritarian power and the
authoritarian power structure doesn't
doesn't allow the people
the people of the country of The
Sovereign Nation
to have their own liberty of what they
want and how they want to operate
doesn't really allow them to do it that
way
and it's really hard
to convince an authoritarian of anything
other than their own self-interest
that's why we as a pro-democracy
coalition have to stand behind democracy
and we have to stand and fight with
people who believe in democracy even if
we don't agree on every line item of
every bill
you do not have to agree
on the exact dollar of what the minimum
wage should be to stand for democracy
you do not have to agree on what we call
Health Care in this country so people
don't go broke because of it
because of a medical bill we do not have
to agree on what to call it
or how far to go to stand for democracy
we can be a coalition
not just here but all around the world
but we got a lot of things to fix here
at home
a lot
but that doesn't mean that we can't pay
attention
to the slow erosion
of liberal thinking
and liberalism around the world we
cannot ignore that
and we must
we must
use our messaging and our narrative as
the main weapon yeah
it's gonna take a lot of votes people
are going to have to move to the ballots
that's the active
ingredient in democracy
but the messaging in the narrative
drives that active ingredient
it engages it
stirs it up
and that's what we are here to do
that's what I'm here to do every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube
Twitter and twitch I'll ask you again go
ahead and subscribe to the YouTube
channel if you're here right now and
you're not subscribed what the hell are
you doing
I don't even care if you hate me hate my
[__] guts yeah that's right love to
hate me
those are my favorite the ones that love
to hate me I mean they [__] love to
hate me they love it
come and hate me all you want just hit
the Subscribe button
hell go support me on patreon so you can
so you can hate watch all you want that
way I'll never stop
I'll never stop
would it be something else if I could
get if I could get
hundreds of hate Watchers to pay five
dollars just to make sure that I never
shut up so they have the ability to hate
watch and be something else wouldn't it
I think that'd be worth it maybe I
should say more crazy [__]
think the [__] I say is that crazy
I really don't it's not complicated to
understand that people want Liberty and
freedom they want equity and equality
meaning they want their own but
realizing that every other person has to
have it for you to receive it
isn't exactly a novel idea I know it
hasn't been around in this country for
very long
but it is it is a good idea
it is a good idea it's actually the path
forward to you know good good situations
where our democracy can deliver as close
as we can get to equity Inequality For
All people in this country race Creed
religion non-religion
background education income
rather you're a migrant or you're you're
you were born here
we should deliver equity and equality to
every single person as much as we can to
almost exact perfection
and the only way to do that is a
democracy that's it and our
constitutional Democratic Republic is
the system that we have
and I believe that even though at the
two-party system isn't always the best
and it shows its weakness here when one
party is not interested in democracy
I think we can still use democracy to
smash up fascism even if it's here in
this country and one party is the
fascist party
the America First Nazis that they are
I'm gonna check in with Gabe Sanchez
here I think we're getting close to the
second hour
or 10 minutes to the second hour which
you know we go to bonehead of the week
and I got a couple Clips I want to show
you too before we get to that we got a
lot of news in bonehead of the week
um because
as as we know it's like you know the
typical [__] but it's the ones
making the news
that are in this oh
you know what while I'm messaging Gabe I
I do have one thing that I don't think
is gonna make it on bonehead so you give
me just say Let me let me see where
um
let's see where Gabe Sanchez is that
let's see what these or how how close we
are to Moon Head oh we're getting pretty
damn close well looky there
son of a [__] we're pretty close so let
me go let me go to this video uh someone
pointed it out and said um uh foreign
I am going to oblige now this is Carrie
Lake everyone knows who Carrie lake is
she's a manga q and honor out in Arizona
she's the one who lost bigly
the Arizona governor's race
um now she's on some sort of [__] I
don't know Trader News Network I don't
know which one it is does it matter
um Newsmax is really mad that they're
not on DirecTV anymore they don't know
how private companies and
uh capitalism works but Kerry lake is
all also doesn't understand how [__]
elections work
which
not [__] surprising but she doesn't
understand how elections work
scary Lake you dumb [__]
um but this is all lies it's all
gaslighting this is all a continuation
to uh mind [__] and delude
the Maga Trump supporters that she's
banned a small coalition
of um absolute cult members
and she's been down at Mar-A-Lago ever
since she lost got her [__] ass
kicked by Katie Hopps listen I ca I
actually cannot believe
that someone didn't beat Katie Hopps
she's a Democrat she may be good at
policy or whatever she may make a great
government she was a shitty candidate
folks
Katie Ops was a shitty [__] candidate
horrible that come at me with it I don't
give a [__] you you can debate me all
you want about how Katie I and I I
wasn't gonna say a goddamn thing at the
time hails to the no that is not a
narrative that I wanted
and I hope she makes a damn good
Governor I really do I hope she makes a
damn good Governor so she can make a
good case when she runs again because I
know she's going to run for a second
term I'm sure of it well maybe not I
don't I don't know I know Katie Hobbs
suffers from a lot of anxiety I think
but that's why her candidacy
was so stymied is because she wasn't
able to talk to reporters she wasn't
able to get out in front of cameras and
typically Executives have to do that
it's part of the job so I hope she
figures out how to do that and she does
it well I hope so not just not just for
her sake but for Arizona's sake Arizona
needs to shape up out there they got
some [__] problems inside of their
institutions Jesus Christ the Republican
party is straight queuing on I mean
straight [__] Q Anon out there and
it's likely that Blake Masters Kerry
Lake and Wendy Rogers and who who knows
who else is going to run for the the
senate seat that will be vacated uh by
Kirsten Cinema because Democrats aren't
going to let that scumbag run as a
Democrat or let her win I'm sure of it
but Gary Lake here oh my [__] god and
True Q Anon fashion
um she just doesn't understand Gabe's
engine she has no clue she just has no
clue she doesn't know how elections work
welcome to the show by the way yeah your
microphone's not on I don't know yeah
there we go all right there I tapped it
I was on mute that's why you know but
yeah so um scary Lake here she doesn't
understand how elections work which is
not what do you mean carry fake Carrie
fake or is Heary Lake
fake scary fake there you go blurry Lake
blurry okay well you know there's a lot
of names you get called yeah
um but this in true Santos fashion here
um she just out right I mean this is
this is [__] crazy and someone
messages to us it's like hey are you
guys gonna goof on this you got damn
right I will I mean Carrie Lake really
is is so irrelevant and this is what
she's trying to do by do this but but
this is sedition folks this is full on
realize this is full-on [__] sedition
Kerry Lake
signed when she had her candidacy she
signed
um something to be a candidate right she
she
was supposed to take the oath that she
won as governor and she doesn't even
know what that oath says and this is
full-on 100
[__] sedition there's just no because
she said she said from the very
beginning well you know as we led up to
the midterm elections uh she was asked
several times
eat on Fox News uh CNN other places
where they were like will you accept the
results of the election she goes I will
accept the results of the election and I
will be the winner and it's like um
but listen to this this is this is wild
she's really getting in the weeds here
and she's really um she's desperate yeah
um to get attention but the attention
that we're going to give her is
completely mockers so it's worth it I'm
again the sunlight's the best
disinfectant we have to be we have to be
the daylight on these [__] to
actually disinfect them so let's do a
little bit of uh cleaning up here with
Gary Lake let's let's listen this is not
long at all for her to get crazy we
cannot have the election stand the judge
should declare me the rightful winner I
am the rightful winner and we should
move on and reclaim our government our
state government has been hijacked and
stolen by a bunch of people who know
this election was fraudulent the cartels
are running our state
okay so the cartels baby uh she's got it
she's got she got to throw a few
buzzwords in there she got to be like oh
there's brown people or yeah the Deep
state is deep with [__] and the [__] is
the same color as Brown and Brown is
doing like she goes on some crazy
scary Lake Carrie fake whatever blurry
Lake whatever her name is
it's uh it's dumbass is really the
actual name right but the idea here's
the thing it doesn't even matter Katie
Hobbs has been sworn in right she's the
governor what are you gonna do the idea
that Carrie likes like well no I don't
like the results of what the judge said
or the decision that the judge said
which again the decision was by the
judge was like let me look at what's
here okay cool so uh yeah I don't see
any voter fraud there is no way that you
won this election well yeah because they
can't provide any evidence of voter
fraud right exactly they're just they're
just like they're evidence their
evidence is there's no way I got less
votes than her and and they're like well
actually actually they counted and you
did yeah well that's the same logic that
Salomon Pena had Solomon Pena literally
his logic was I went to every door
in my area
and I should have won meanwhile if you
if somebody comes to your door there
there are like a couple scenarios one
the person's like ah I don't want to
deal with that they don't answer they do
answer the door but the problem is when
you confront someone and say hey I'm so
and so on I'm running can I guarant can
I like you know uh guarantee your vote
and the person's gonna tell you what
they what you want to hear
to make you leave so like can I can I
like count on your vote and then they
say uh yeah sure sounds good and they go
thanks great so by their math right
which again is um very rudimentary math
the idea that they're like if I ask the
person they tell me what I want to hear
confirmation bias then of course I'm
going to be the winner and if I go to
every door and all these people say yes
I will vote for you face to face they
tell me then then I had to have win and
that literally and I'm not I'm not
paraphrasing I'm not joking he literally
said the reason that he won and he knows
that he won was because he went to all
of these different doors knocked on the
doors and got them got that person and
say yeah I will vote for you and that's
just not how it works people that is not
how it works okay I mean
um I can imagine that some of you are
like yeah sure I'll vote for if you get
off my front porch right yeah like yeah
sure yeah as long as I don't have to
sign anything yeah I'll just tell you
what you want to hear years ago I was um
in the insurance business is horrible
and we had to do cold calls it was
horrible that's brutal one of the most
beautiful brutal things I've ever done
in my life but uh one thing that that I
did
um as a young and a pup in in the
businesses I I would go door knock you
know try to try to sell people Insurance
you talk about I mean try to get people
to vote for his one thing trying to sell
them into Jesus Christ right and it's
difficult but I I had a few guns pulled
on me I had a few threats you know
kicking my ass or you know gonna gonna
call the police or whatever get off my
crap you know a lot of that stuff yeah
yeah but a lot of it was yeah yeah sure
um just call me next week I'll call you
next week and uh and we'll set up a time
and we'll just no not anyone nothing and
you're like okay great see you then
right yeah now not gonna happen what's
gonna happen same way same way they're
just like yeah sure I'll vote I'll say
I'll vote for you if you get off my
[__] front board you're like yeah
yeah I'll go out with you or like yeah
I'll go to prom with you if you just
come by and ask me later all right
here's my number yeah right hello evix
you've called the uh hotline rejection
number you know it's like that word yeah
it's just one of those things but this
is hilarious that that she is and I
don't know what what the hell is this
show let's see it's called um Joe Pags
just talk radio doesn't have to be
boring to be boring Joe Pags I mean I
guess it doesn't but um if this is your
uh
just got the mic up to the face you know
what all serious you know what you know
what he does provide pretty good content
for entertainment I'm just saying it's
entertaining right I mean an idiot and a
complete denialist right you must throw
any sort of reputation they had to their
name and any sort of Merit which I don't
even know at this point
but the idea that I mean this is the sad
truth that these people this is the
reality they live in they go around
they're yelling at the [__] clouds
like Donald Trump saying Joe Biden and
saying that it's well we watched the
video yesterday we watched the video
yesterday yeah and now we know why he
did that video the Durham the Durham
story was gonna drop he knew it was
gonna drop they I said I said yesterday
when we were watching I'm like look he's
trying to get his what he wants people
to say in the threads on Twitter what he
wants his supporters to say about the
[__] truth that's gonna come out he
wants you to know what lies to tell and
in true fashion yesterday afternoon we
find out this [__] Durham Bill Barr
story
and that and and the investigation into
Russia that's why he was so focused in
that video on Russia in the 2016
campaign not the 2020 election he
wouldn't vote he was focused on 2016.
and the reason why is because the world
was about to find out that again he's a
criminal corrupt [__] scumbag and
that he is the deep [__] State swamp yep
I've I've I've I put that together today
deep [__] State swamp I don't know I
think I mean it's a kind of long but
it's good you know I mean it gets it
gets the point across it gets there
right yeah yeah and you can just say the
deep [__] State or the or the the Trump
swamp you know you can like shorten it
yeah yeah I mean a lot of you know a lot
of Republicans want to talk about we got
to drain the swamp and in order to get
the swamp out like a lot of I mean there
were the 20 or so Republicans during the
house Speaker vote that were like Kevin
McCarthy is part of the swamp and we got
to drain the a swamp and I mean good for
them for calling out Kevin McCarthy
being part of the swamp especially in
relation to Trump even though some of
those 20 people voted for Trump who is
like the [__] swamp Master he is the
Swamp Thing and the idea that they
weren't able to connect the two but just
associate one of them
okay yesterday I I released a clip of me
comparing um sex toys and guns so I'm
gonna do something here and this might
make a pretty good clip I don't know
maybe maybe not we'll see
um You Ever Had swamp ass you read swamp
at you know what swamp ass is yeah yes
right right you sitting on like a chair
and you get out of the chair and even
the chair is like [__] wet and guys
get this a lot more than because guys
are [__] gross right yeah yeah
[__] gross They Don't Really they
don't take enough showers probably just
disgusting human beings men and they
Swan a lot and you sweat in a place
right that gives you swamp ass now
Trump and his deep State actions here
are like the swamp ass on us right so
like our country's swamp ass there's you
can't get really rid of it I mean you
got to take shower after shower you got
to make sure meticulously that you're
clean and that you're driving maybe you
throw some Botox shots right
or or some some powder or something you
might need you might need some baby
powder to get rid of the swamp but you
gotta actively make sure that you don't
have swamp ass and I think that's what
we're dealing with here I don't know
what you think about this comparison
between I mean look I think and swamp
ass oh yeah I know I I think you agree I
think I think Trump is the swamp ass of
government Administration so now we're
at Deep deep [__] State swamp ass yeah
deep State [__] swamp that's a little
too long I mean that's almost as long as
George Santos's real name right George
Anthony devolder dos Santos DeSantis oh
Santos speaking speaking of um Anthony
or whatever his name is my guess is uh
he's um a feature in the bonehead of the
week oh yeah he's he's probably he's not
only a feature but like uh I see the
benefit he's the how many times he how
long have we known about George Santos
not that long right uh we found out
about him at the end of last year so I'm
not going to get during the holidays
during the holidays that's when he's
Christmas right yeah so think about it
because we're it's it's the end of
January yeah January 2018 to knowing
about him okay so get
get in perspective I'm not gonna give
away today's thing
but George Santos so far is three for
four on the bonehead of the week like
he's three he didn't win that first week
because no one really had him yet he
wasn't really a household name not that
anyone really knew his name or himself
do we still know his name I don't know
if we no every day there's something new
he doesn't quite know his name I mean
this week if you thought last week was
crazy this week was even more stuff
it's just in oh my God it just doesn't
it I know there's gonna be more drop on
this idiot oh yeah no no I believe me
I've SP so I'm I'm currently working on
uh a story about George Santos oh really
and I'm just I'm talking with some
people and I spoke with so can we say
anything about it no no no okay okay but
can you give any kind of information
should we should we do it in the bone
end because I know he's in bonehead he's
in bone I can I can like mention one
okay just because I'm still working on
it trying to trying to verify some
information yeah let's do this let's go
to a break because we're in this top of
the second hour let's go to a break in
bonehead of the week right after these
messages
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that I'm struggling with I
chose Babble mag Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
[Music]
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
we've been playing a parody commercial
for quite some time Abel Gabe Sanchez
you always are way ahead of the group
and I just noticed this that the Trump
supporter in the video he's holding a
trump 2024 cardboard design that he used
to Sharpie you're always ahead of the
curve always
[Music]
way ahead
what is gonna happen it's the second
hour on Friday you know what that means
bonehead of the week bonehead of the way
here this is my favorite segment that's
pretty great it's pretty I love it I
love it I I like bone of the week here's
why because uh it it's a good it's a
good exclamation point on the week it
kind of gives us the ability to kind of
do a little bit of like a a review even
though it's like a review of the last 24
hours because it's all these [__]
idiots work
um they never give us the opportunity to
really put a bonehead in from Monday we
used to try to do that but it never
worked because people are like what what
did that person do and then they've done
like three things but um you're not
going to be disappointed today I'm not
sure exactly why we have the alpha that
we have or the DM I have an idea of
these stories um but I'm gonna let you
explain that when we get to it
um because I I didn't usually you you
tell me hey this is AC and DM but I'm
just now just now learning who yeah yeah
Alpha cook and the DM is
um but let's get into it let's let's go
to bonehead of the week
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
bonehead of the week this is your
addition
of this week's bonehead of the week oh
boy it's been uh um a bone-headed week
there's been a lot of bone-headed things
yesterday uh on the show we went through
uh Captain bonehead Donald Trump's
little video and we found out yesterday
afternoon why he made the video as a
preemptive
um why argument gaslighting of what you
know was going to be exposed to the
American people about how corrupt and
how swampy and how deep [__] State
Donald Trump and his administration
actually were so these are the
contestants on this week's bone end of
the week of course Donald Trump himself
the Cheeto dust q and honor and then
also uh John Durham
which I don't it's did you have to make
his face today is this the first time
he's ended up on this or no this is the
first time that John Durham and I mean
like look we could have made fun of John
Durham for losing the other two lawsuits
or cases that he went into code for
court for but uh he never you mean he
never really the Sham investigations
that he yeah yeah yeah I mean again
prosecution Clinton yeah
um Hillary Clinton I would almost argue
that that John Durham unless you're
really like it's kind of an inside
baseball reference like I feel like John
Durham isn't a name that you would
normally know and it definitely wasn't a
name that was evoked during the day well
unless unless you're very familiar with
the laptop talk yeah yeah yeah if you
are very familiar with the [__]
laptop talk all the lies built around
the laptop the laptop from hell and if
you're familiar with that then you would
be very familiar with Durham because
they had High Hopes I mean they were
gonna lock up Hillary Clinton they were
gonna lock up Barack Obama for spying on
campaigns I mean they were going to
prove that not only did Donald Trump not
collude with Russia but it was Hillary
Clinton that colluded with Russia to
make sure Donald Trump didn't win I mean
all this just [__] [__] nonsense
they wanted to prove that the p-tape
isn't real which it is I'm sure of it oh
yeah um they wanted to prove all these
things and and Durham was their big hope
right yeah he was the one that was going
to prosecute these people and put them
in gitmo or whatever the hell these
Cuban honors believe and he did none of
that
um as a matter of fact there was the
opposite kind of happening in this
investigation that they covered up but
we'll get into that also we have
the average nor every day Republican
George Santos
um he loves his lies everyone knows he
loves his lies the problem is he's not
very good at it
um he's just not a professional liar
like some of the other professional
politicians out there like
maybe our dishonorable mention today but
let's let's start because really
honestly the John Durham and the Donald
Trump thing it's one and the same isn't
it yeah usually we have like two
different stories here but this is where
the the idiotic universes Collide is
bonehead of the week sometimes and we
have a huge Collision here of boneheads
with John Durham and Donald Trump and
I'm gonna drag Bill Barr into this
section of this so
for those of you who do not know uh and
who are not familiar with all the laptop
language that is the lies and delusion
of Q Anon John Durham was going to be
their great hope to to charge and
imprison and
I don't know they were gonna execute
them put them again I don't know what
the [__] they were gonna remove Joe
Biden and Jimmy they were going to use
the tyrannical government that they
don't like right to have and imprisoned
someone and put them again to install
and that's all addictive I will say this
that it that is definitely a recurring
punishment that people on the right have
for anyone who uh they feel is is the
enemy they go send them to gitmo or
right put him on a bar like uh Jenny
Thomas was put him on a barge outside of
gitmo like what the [__] there's a well
why well because she hears the thing the
reason why Jeannie Thomas wants him on a
barge outside gitmo is because we've
exposed and Democrats Senate Democrats
specifically exposed uh Claire mccaskill
being one of them uh the former senator
from Missouri and Al Franken they
exposed the fact that they were
torturing people I don't know if you
heard of waterboarding or not but that's
why they're so obsessed that's why
they're so obsessed with gitmo because
they think that's where people get
waterboarded right which is that
is that considered international waters
out there well so that's what I'm saying
is that's what probably Jeannie Thomas
that's what I mean you got to get inside
of their [__] little cult deluded
Minds yeah of why they say some of this
stupid [__] in the first place it's not
again I I told everyone in the beginning
of the show in the first 30 minutes that
there is a difference between opinion
and belief your belief is not an opinion
automatically it's not opinions are
based in fact right you can have a
certain set of facts me and Gabe can
agree on three or four facts and we can
form different opinions based on the
facts we've done it on this show we
typically agree but we don't always
agree I I we disagreed yesterday when I
said Trump absolutely should be on
Twitter I hope he's on Twitter he needs
to be on Facebook I I'm I'm itching for
this little fat slob to get on Facebook
so we can out microphone him that's my
thought you have a little different yeah
it was just for Facebook I was like I
don't care about Twitter well right
Facebook was the one that was
but we're using the same set of facts to
form our opinions now
there is a difference between opinions
and belief belief is just I mean it can
your belief can be based in fact an
opinion right yeah I mean most of my
beliefs being very misconstrued and
manipulated in your own uh determination
or like interpretation it could be like
the video we just watched at Kerry Lake
where she believes that a judge can just
overturn an election and make her the
governor of uh there's is there I don't
know that there's any mechanism for a
judge in Arizona to be like uh you're
the governor oh you're you know what
that's it yeah I mean it's the Oprah the
Oprah meme yeah you're the governor
you're the governor you're the governor
the [__] are you talking about this yeah
it doesn't I mean it doesn't I mean
their logic is is that there's a lack of
logic right it never makes any sense and
when they try to explain something they
come up with some what about ISM on
something that actually contradicts
their own point that they're trying to
make so they end up more or less
defeating their own Point by themselves
and you just kind of just sit by and
watch and be like okay all right but the
idea that you'd be you know for her
example
or any other Republican where they're
like oh no it's it was the Deep State
and the judge has to be the one that
appoints I mean it's almost as effective
of like an argument as Donald Trump
saying if I think about declassifying
documents they're Declassified right and
that's how the world works and that's
just not based in reality and none of
these Republicans are and John Durham is
a great example of that well it's the
same way with the documents mind control
stuff because we're going to talk about
Trump here is that it's a belief you
believe that that happens but it's not
an opinion because there's no basis in
fact right like you gotta you gotta you
gotta have a few facts about your your
little your little thoughts and your
your your thinky space using its is
energy there to form an opinion now your
opinion can be that the president United
States is sitting president United
States can declassify any information
that he wants that that is a that's a
fact it can't happen that way but just
because that's a fact doesn't mean that
your stupid belief
is based in that fact because it just
isn't but let's let's go to the facts of
this story on Durham and Trump and why
they ended up on bone in the week
Lawrence tribe has it here
um his commentary is on Twitter when
Durham unexpectedly found evidence of
crimes committed by rather than against
Trump he and bar deliberately deceived
the nation into thinking the opposite
sounds familiar almost on like every
issue
um this deep dive by the New York Times
is as jaw dropping as anything read in
the past decade I did read part of this
I I didn't read the exact whole thing
from start to finish but literally
almost every single [__] sentence of
it you're like Jesus Christ oh Jesus
Christ are you [__] kidding me off
for [__] sake like you could use a
thousand hand Palm or face bomb emojis I
mean it is one of those things that is
like totally not surprising you know
especially when they're like oh yeah so
you know Bill Barr handed this off to
John Durham to look into John Durham
looks into it and goes oh oh okay
um so it turns out uh he actually did
some he made some boo-boos uh and he
wasn't actually the victim here and so
the idea that they'll be that you know
they if they don't like the answer
that they want or if they don't get the
the confirmation bias that they need to
continue with something then they'll you
know toss it off to the side I mean
where are these Twitter files baby huh
right exactly but this is this is the
the um the ability of the Republicans to
reverse engineer everything uh I know I
keep going back to this story and it
doesn't seem like that like how is the
Eminem story this story I'm telling you
it's the exact same [__] exact same [__]
folks they're reverse engineering they
tried to reverse engineer something that
didn't exist and because they were using
a system that is relies on [__] facts
to some degree to do what they wanted to
do which was prosecute people and
prosecute people in front of a jury of
their peers they were damn it was damn
difficult to reverse engineer this and
what's funny about it which is not
surprising is that when they started to
reverse engineer they found crimes for
DOT that Donald Trump committed because
what happened is is they went to the
Italian government because what they
wanted from the Italian government was
to reverse engineer their narrative they
wanted the reverse engineering they
wanted proof and evidence or at least a
narrative that showed that there was
corruption from Clinton not and
collusion from Clinton not Donald Trump
I mean in a way in a way they kind of
went about the scientific method it just
ended up proving themselves wrong right
so their idea was like this is uh but
the scientific method doesn't reverse
engineer the results right well in most
cases yeah yeah and that's why they
failed so they failed
so great here right and their failure
here is important right I mean a lot of
people are upset about this and they're
pissed about this but folks this is this
is why us being in a pro-democracy
coalition and really just standing
behind facts and Truth is important but
this exercise of showing who these
people are and exposing themselves
especially Bill Barr because Durham you
know and really honestly there's a lot
of legal Minds out there when Durham got
assigned to this case they were like oh
well Durham he's got credibility and
blah blah blah
um you need to recant your statements
you need to get out from the people and
say you were [__] wrong you were dead
wrong you can't believe you're wrong but
you're wrong wrong wrong wrong wrong
wrong and you will try better on your
analysis of this stuff because it does
it didn't matter the the vehicle of
Durham right because Durham was just
assigned again to re-engine to to
reverse engineer the result that they
want wanted not to actually seek facts
and then prosecute based on those facts
because what ended up happening as a
reverse engineering this idea that the
Italian government was somehow gonna
tell them oh yeah the clintons were the
ones that were colluding with Russia
they found out that Trump committed
crimes in Italy because they were the
Italians like oh yeah that crime doesn't
exist but hey by the way look at this
crime now no one knows what this crime
is because in this article it does not
lay out uh what the crimes are they're
not reporting on that as of yet
um but my guess is is that it does have
to do with the collusion
um it's the crime I mean because they
you know they they look into the Russia
investigation Russia Russia Russia hoax
hoax hoax all that [__] but the idea
that they
went in to confirm their own beliefs
right their own they just wanted
confirmation bias to be like yes he was
the victim and these crimes really were
against him and he didn't do anything
wrong and when they go to test that you
know Theory or that bias then they find
out oh actually he Trump did do so the
evidence the evidence of collusion
wasn't from Clinton was it was but it
does it does go to show you that once
more just like the obstruction committee
right of the Republican party in the
house is that their investigation either
turns out to be a total dud or it
reveals something that oh the person
that we were going in to protect and
with an investigation turns out that
person actually did something wrong and
this whole deep State plot was actually
Trump and not anyone else against Trump
right and so you find like this
so Trump was what is almost four years
now is what the investigation that was
going on and they still came up with
nothing other than finding out that
Trump actually was involved well they
tried to prosecute a couple people but
failed miserably right and and the
reason why is because
a jury of their peers went I mean you
have to it has to be you know something
more than this and they acquitted them
of the charges that Durham manufactured
and again it's a manufacturing and
reverse manufacturing of this idea now I
know I played
um a lot of this video yesterday and I'm
not gonna I promise to the audience
then I'm not gonna play the the uh the
entirety of this video today I promise I
promise but I do think it is important
to watch part of this and understand now
uh now that we know what we know about
the New York Times article and the
actual investigation and more to the
idea that they've found crime that Trump
committed probably to do with collusion
um and they covered it up and they being
Bill Barr I don't [__] cookies why uh
there we go okay
I don't want cookies I mean I'm trying
I'm I'm trying to you know get a
swimmer's body here okay okay so we're
gonna watch part of this and I don't
know exactly the time stamp because this
thing's long we mocked it yesterday so
if you want to see uh us mocking this
just go to our channel the Tony Michaels
podcast just go to YouTube the Tony
Michaels podcast it would be episode
number I don't know what episode number
yesterday this is today's 319 so yeah so
it's 3 18. maybe 318 is the episode that
you're looking for and we did I don't
know it's like 45 minutes on this stupid
five minute video that this guy did
um but here is the Cheeto dust q and
honor and he's going to talk about this
what Russia hoax but let's let's watch
part of this but they asked that all
data on their phones never done this
before
be wiped off
in some cases they said oh I'm sorry it
was a mistake can you imagine what we
would have found
with Paige
and struck
and all of them all of them who in the
Mueller team was in charge of leaking
secret information and fake news stories
to dishonest journalists of which are
many okay repetitions
why did numerous FBI ncia analysts go
out
and purchase professional liability okay
let's go for this government agencies
directly or indirectly for their role in
spreading domestic disinformation like
the FBI did with Twitter paid them three
million six hundred thousand dollars so
far that we know of
domestic disinformation what the [__]
does that mean we didn't we missed that
yesterday but again this is just a rant
and again I'm going to fast forward here
again and just play because you could
pick any part of this video and listen
to like four seconds of it and be like
Jesus Christ he's he's deranged listen
what was the role of federal agents and
informants and pressing the crowd toward
the capital
on January 6. you you you you were you
were you were I mean this goes on and on
but who could have been the bad guy
this is this is more of a story in that
again the video that we watched
yesterday and and I would encourage you
strongly to go watch our episode
yesterday if you didn't catch it where
we mocked the [__] because the video in
that in its entirety yeah you don't want
to it's like almost two minutes to have
the first question he's like I've got it
uh I got a question I got a question
okay and then he goes for two minutes
almost two minutes and does it has a
question and then he gets to the point
where he's like who do I have
yeah yeah
that's like the funniest uh part of the
whole clip is when he does the race
that's the quickest that is the quickest
question he had yesterday he was like
who's Reyes who's the guy we all know
where he came from and that was it and
then boom he was on to the next question
it's funny because he's like the
question is who is reups and then he's
like we know the answer here's yes that
clip here he's like do we though on
January 6th and who is raps tell me
about raps where does he come from I
think we know
then why do you need to know if you
already know but the point is is that
there is there was a congressional
committee that found out who Ray Epps
was and what his involvement in January
6 was and it was nothing he was just a
[__] idiot there yeah there's footage
that put him at that testimony there's
[__] testimony of them interviewing
him but the biggest question of the
decade
we all know where he came from yeah I
don't know [__] mothers birth canal I
don't know what the [__] they want to
talk about right but the other thing too
is again this is this is his attempt at
distraction from the crimes he committed
on January 6 but the part of the video
because he goes because he can't just do
a video on a certain subject he's got to
get off on tangents and but the subject
was hey this Durham information about me
committing crimes in Italy probably with
collusion with Russia is gonna drop that
they hit it and Bill Barr is a corrupt
piece of [__] and he's one of the most
dangerous people that was ever as an
attorney general of ours
that story is going to drop so I gotta
get this out there so my people know
what to say when the story drop all fake
news here's why it's fake news because
Donald Trump said this our Jesus
reassured us he reassured us that he's
being set up here and really honestly
the main story here is this is that we
have to elect folks in this country that
are serious people when you elect a
criminal corrupt [__] a creole a
career corrupt [__] like Donald
Trump a con man a money launderer when
you elect him to a higher office
especially the president's United States
where he has the authority to appoint an
attorney general he is not going to
point the attorney general in the
interest of the country he's going to
appoint the attorney general in the
interest of him his own [__] crimes
he's gonna appoint him so he can cover
up his crimes and that is what has led
us to have John Durham and Donald Trump
on the bonehead of the week
um and I don't think anyone should be
very surprised Yeah by that at all
honestly I mean they're all connected
you know uh the idea that they're like
I'm the most persecuted president of all
time and I'm totally innocent look look
man we went eight years with Obama there
was no investigation the closest thing
that was crazy for them was the goddamn
tan suit
well and the Dijon mustard oh right
right Dijon mustard gate was serious
yeah yeah yeah when he ordered Dijon
mustard for his hand because we all know
from the gray Poupon commercials
um that Dijon mustard is for elite if
anyone remembers the uh the Wayne's
World commercial right that they made
from the from the movie gray Poupon did
you know that that uh company they they
invented the idea that Dijon mustard was
the better of the muster more Elite of
the mustards before that no one no one
liked no one liked oh yeah I mean yeah
if you go back and look at the history
of that of that marketing campaign where
the limo like the the limo pulls up with
the old dude inside the old dude he's
like gray Poupon you know and he's like
they that was all manufactured in our
society and culture with marketing to to
mind [__] people to think that Dijon
muster was the better and more I mean
it's in a glass jar it's got this nice
little little font to it it's got a
French flag I think on it right colors
you know right but but it it was great
marketing because because even in our
own [__] political body when when
Barack Obama prefers Dijon mustard over
original mustard and he orders he
doesn't order gray Poupon he just says
Dijon it's a type of mustard yeah yeah
and because that's what he preferred on
that sandwich and like yeah sure the
entire world's like oh my God I can't
believe he's shutting like Dijon a lot
you know yellow mustard is like whatever
but if you add a little spice you know
right ground mustard some John mustard
look
I'm not gonna Kink change someone or
mustard shame someone right our or
condiment shame must or condiment change
condiment yeah
I'm not gonna well I wouldn't I wouldn't
condom machine him either you know I
don't care whatever condoms you want to
use whether you want to use them or not
it's up to you just make sure it's
consensual condoms that's all like
that's all we we as a society ask the
point is is that it is ridiculous to
think that we our country can't be mind
[__] by something when when just the
simple fact that the biggest Scandal was
tan suit and Dijon mustard yeah when the
entire history of Dijon mustard is that
Dijon mustard actually was looked at as
the shitty mustard it was the mustard of
of the pores before and then yeah which
is kind of interesting because they're
like kind of the same color they're both
tan you know I don't know maybe maybe
Fox News has something against tanzoos
but then again Mitch McConnell and all
those other [__] idiots wear tan
suits all the time
right but that's different they're white
oh that's right I'm just say I'm just
saying I mean that's white I mean that's
that is correct right so should we do
alpha cut or dmvers which one do you
want to do first I pulled an audible
we're gonna go with DM we'll go with DM
first oh so you switched it on me I
literally just switched it like two
minutes ago oh it depends on what you
want to do do you want to go no no let's
let's do let's do the audible let's pull
the audible so um but I do want to show
who was going to be DM here oh yeah we
won't do that specific story but this
was our DM but Gabe Sanchez Matt gatz
representative Matt venmo Gantz was
gonna be our and I say that on purpose I
know audience you know they're like
that's not is that really how you say
yes that's how I say it
um because it's not spelled Gates it's
spelled gets and again
anytime I want to say it like that every
time so if he ever hears me say it
pisses him off that's my only intention
with it really uh and I just like to say
his name wrong [__] him but we pulled an
audible at the very last moment here see
this is how bonehead works even while
we're on the show we could be changing
it because now our dishonorable mention
he worked his way up uh and a last at
the last second Tucker Carlson is our
Dishonored momentum so Gabe Sanchez tell
us why we have the audible here so if I
could I would put the whole Republican I
just [__] throw an elephant on here
if I could and just be the whole
Republican party because this morning
the actual police footage was released
and it it it is horrifying to watch uh
when the cops just stand there for a
moment
and let the attack happen on Paul Pelosi
so now so that's the video because we
we're gonna have two big video footages
dropped yeah Paul Pelosi dropped and
then the police officers killing right
right sorry that one is going to be
dropping so that one well we can take a
look at that one uh but the the video
before that is and Tucker Carlson was
the one that really pushed this idea
right after it happened in the at the
end of October I think was like the
29th 28th something like that uh is is
when he was attacked
and immediately that night
Republicans or sorry immediately that
time because we were on we were on the
air we were live right when people were
trying to push this idea oh he was a
leftist and he was uh you're talking
about Paul Pelosi being attacked in
their home by a manga assassin with a
hand exactly uh and so David DuPage or
whatever his name is
in real time we were on the show and we
were debunking these lies that were
being told this guy was a nudist and the
leftist and he was a liberal and he was
this and that he's part of the he was
actually a fan of Pelosi and blah blah
blah and it was really easy to debunk
right like as we were doing it live on
the air we're pulling up we're pulling
up actual screenshots or clip or you
know uh photos or that show the opposite
of what they were exactly and so uh
sorry de Pepe de Pepe I don't I don't
[__] care what his last name is
anyways the point is
immediately after Republicans jumped on
you know uh don Jr posted a photo with
underwear and a hammer and said here's
the strike before Halloween
right before Halloween and so
Tucker Carlson who is probably the worst
of the batch in terms of spreading
misinformation and it's not a new
station it's just a [__]
Entertainment station in an
entertainment show which they legally uh
had to prove in court so that he
couldn't get sued that's why we don't
call ourselves news here I mean we we
commentate on news but we're not right
we're not news and so Tucker Carlson was
you know out there beating the [__]
drum
and came out and said oh why are they
hiding this stuff why won't they show us
the footage why was this guy in his
underwear Bubba all of these were lies
the idea that he was he was some gay
lover of Paul Pelosi he was in the clip
you sent me I've got this clip yeah in
this clip there's a he talks about and
then he also talks to Larry Elder and
then they basically talk about like what
are they hiding why is why is the
footage off limits why can't we see it
right it's all it's all um questions
that are geared towards to to pump more
misinformation and you know they're
disingenuous questions to lead to lead
his followers into believing more more
[__] about
the facts of the attack right now
now that the tape is released all this
stuff is debunked of course I mean other
it happened exactly like they said it
happened right either Tucker Carlson
tonight would be like can we believe
that that's actually the tape yeah what
what how do we know it how do we know
that we didn't doctor how do we know
this wasn't done after the fact on a
Hollywood set do we are we really dumb
enough to to not be able to just
disseminate information when it's
presented to us as facts I mean this is
that I'm just asking questions yeah
we're just asking I'm not saying it's
that's what it is I'm just asking the
question
of mind I'm here [__] you and hypnotize
you into believing whatever you want to
believe is the truth but let's listen to
um this [__] lunatic go on and on and
on about lies without any strength I
guarantee he will not say anything about
it no going forward he'll never mention
it again he'll never mention the lines
that he'll never mention it no it's been
more than a month since Paul Pelosi was
attacked in his home on a Friday night
in San Francisco
and you know we do a pretty good mocking
of him but wait the reason why he sounds
like that that Cadence it's just think
of it if you have children out there or
you've ever had to deal with children to
try to like you know kind of do the
whole little little lie thing to get
them to do what you want yeah you take
that tone you're like look yeah this is
what we're gonna do yeah hey look we are
going to go to the ice cream store but
don't tell your mother right again it's
it's the whole tone he's talking to him
like they're little children because
they truly are okay let's let's listen
so what exactly happened in the Pelosi
house that night well there have been a
lot of conspiracy theories about it and
people who've put those forward have
been attacked for it you're crazy so
there's one way to end this debate
immediately and it would be a
constitutional way to end it in fact we
should be demanding it and that's to see
the body cam footage from that night
because these police are public servants
they work for the rest of us they have
no right to hide that
but the police for some reason have
refused to release that body cam footage
we get body cam footage every day okay
so again this is just a [__]
bolt-faced line we don't get body
footage every day they they have there
is a legal process in most States
that that the the law enforcement agency
can't just [__] put the body cam
footage on YouTube there's a legal
process that happens in Most states
right you can't release evidence and
then potentially ruin any sort of
prosecution of of a seclusion right but
again that Tucker Carlson would know
that while he does know that but he's an
idiot are we too expected Tucker Carlson
doesn't know exactly what he's doing do
we really think that Tucker Carlson
doesn't know that he's mind [__] his
audience are we really supposed to
believe that I mean this is this is the
[__] that these are just questions these
are just questions that I'm asking that
you have to answer for yourself I mean
this is the stupidity that he does but
again I I wanna I wanna let everyone
know that what he's saying here the the
last idea the last [__] uh commentary
that he had on body cam footage is
absolutely [__] yeah that that there
are some states that yes it's very easy
to get body cam footage there are some
states it's very hard to get body
footage there are laws that the the
state legislators pass and frankly some
of them are [__] they are it is
[__] that we do not get access to
body cam footage uh when I don't know
like police murder
of a black man an innocent black man and
murdered him and it is kind of egregious
so but again he uses he uses crumbs
of
predisposed biases to form these
questions
to make sure that his audience
believes what he's saying by asking it
it's [__] propaganda 101 but let's
continue with the [__] and let's see
how he framed this up in the news
business but they won't release this and
only they not release it they are intent
to not releasing it into pape's federal
court case a judge has just issued a
protective order Banning the release of
sensitive information in this case and
that would include the body cam footage
what is going on here why are they
hiding this is there because they're
going to prosecute him Tucker Carlson
and they don't want the evidence out in
the open before they get to the
Discovery phase of the prosecution you
[__] because there's a whole there's
a whole uh
uh process that goes into so let's say
this is a jury court right uh you're
you're not allowed and obviously it's
very difficult in today's world where
it's like how can you not of or like how
can you avoid all of the media social
media news Clips someone says this you
see an article here whatever obviously
it's you're playing the honor System but
the idea that they're like well why
don't we just release the the body cam
footage like well first off if they
release the body cam footage then
it would really prove the point that
Democrats and what the authorities were
saying not and it would it and it would
totally disprove what Republicans were
pushing
but obviously our legal system requires
us to hold on to evidence and not reveal
it to not sway because again you know
you're innocent until proven guilty
right and so this idea that if we were
to reveal or ex you know until a
a the investigation is up and they have
been
um indicted or prosecuted on something
like they're not going to release
evidence you know it's not going to
happen unless they have all their ducks
in a row and they know exactly how
they're going to go against the the the
people that are that are guilty or being
prosecuted or whatever it might be uh
before they have a chance to you know
actually go through some proceeding and
so Tucker Carlson here is like well why
don't we just do this
well I don't why can't we why can't we
just release the footage that would be
okay I think he knows but he knows
exactly but he wants it's the [__]
Eminem stuff all over again he's
creating this fake outrage over
something he knows the answer to and
whether or not he's really triggered by
this stuff oh he's not the idea is all
fake yeah the idea that they have people
on their staff that know exactly what
they can and can't say to avoid legal
issues
the fact that he's like you know he's
always like I'm just asking questions
here I am telling you to get mad at this
thing but really I know the answer well
I mean I mean uh as soon as the news
broke that Paul Pelosi had his head
bashed in by a hammer um they were
excited I mean oh yeah he was in his
underwear it was his gay mother yeah how
did he get in they couldn't wait to make
up [__] about this story they couldn't
wait to make up [__] and I'm sure Larry
Elder here does a great job of making up
[__] about this story let's watch what's
infuriating I mean I should just say I
you know I think Paul Posey is a very
nice man I've met him and I like Paul
Pelosi so I wouldn't I don't I'm not
interested in what pop Posey was doing
there and I wouldn't be doing it myself
right now if they hadn't used it to
attack their political opponents oh this
is January 6th the right wing is
attacking the Pelosi I mean they use
this story to attack their political
opponents so we have an absolute right
and obligation to get to the bottom of
it correct
that's right I said something snarky
about it after I made sure that Paul
Pelosi uh was going to recover fully and
oh well well oh you know cover fully
yeah before anyone realized if there was
going to be a long-term brain damage to
having a [__] Hammer bashed into your
skull
he act like Paul Pelosi fell down a
couple stairs yeah why don't I know he
just had a scrape on his knee right and
people get pissed off at me when I when
I [__] dance on these anti-vaxxers
grave when they die from from not
getting vaccinated because that's why
they're dying from now at least you know
the outcome that's right you right I
what are you gonna do and and here this
[__] is he's like well look look
I made sure he was okay before I yeah I
I made sure he at least had a pulse
before I made a joke right I mean even
if even if he didn't I probably still
would have made it but you know this
piece of [__] I don't know it is what it
is and you wonder why he didn't become
the governor owner of California oh
thank God right well someone as someone
who was in California I just gotta say
thank goodness I mean he was he was
[__] body slammed and had no chance
but there was the possibility right well
I mean he was on the ballot so which is
weird
um how that how the uh you know there's
there's obviously things early on for
for Larry Elder where he was like I'm
not gonna run I don't want to run
California's recall law is weird though
it is because because they they've had a
lot of recalls I mean that's how Arnold
Schwarzenegger became Governor right
well yeah they had recalls but then
because of covid they were able to
extend it and get the amount of
signatures needed to actually put
forward a candidate and they put Larry
Elder who is an idiot uh who is no you
don't say you don't say well let's let's
let's hear let's get more of a whiff of
this idiocy other conservatives were
attacked for speculating that something
might have might have gone wrong or
something might have be might be
different than what they're telling us
uh so you're quite right we ought to
know what the story is but we were
attacked it was you used to show how
insensitive and cold and callous
conservatives are right before the
midterms yeah
they're all
they're up to Paul Pelosi and then they
use it against us those sons of [__]
like give me a [__] break come on you
don't expect me to politicize your
insensitivity to humanity get the [__]
out of here I'm gonna I'm gonna use that
and leverage that every single time
against you [__] idiots because you
want to destroy the app do you want to
destroy the possibility of Papa Lucy and
Nancy Pelosi even to be living in this
country let alone the the majority of
people in SF where they live in San
Francisco you [__] scumbags I mean
scumbag and it really it really comes
back to the idea that I mean also great
just moment in this Freeze Frame here of
Tucker Carlson
but you gotta you gotta look at this and
you gotta understand that this is their
attempt to get back at the Ashley
Babbitt stories right Ashley Babbitt
insurrectionist showed up to the Capitol
crazy crazy mind [__] by right-wing
news and Fox News and right-wing media
all that stuff and driven by Trump
speech in Trump's Direction and she
showed up and she you know she [__]
around and she found out right she got
shot by someone who was protecting doing
their job again you know blue lives
matter
you don't you don't hear Republicans say
that on on January 6th since I know the
outcome she [__] around and found out
in the face I'm sorry I just I can't I'm
sorry I'm sorry [__] around and
finding out goes wrong
um so but this is I think this is
honestly in response and you hear that
in Tucker Carlson saying like oh they
want to talk about this is January 6th
yeah it is because you guys have spread
a bunch of propaganda and misinformation
about how the Deep State and Democrats
and liberals and leftists and all these
people are trying to control you and
oppress you and all this [__] and
that's not what's happening right you
have a bunch of right-wing Nut Job media
hosts and pundits who push this idea to
a bunch of other susceptible vulnerable
people who are very gullible
because that's what they are and as a
result they go out and actually
facilitate this crime and they hear
things like Ashley Babbitt was a patriot
and she was doing her Duty and she was
standing up for the Constitution and she
was making sure that we actually
facilitated the proper protocols in
place to to uh to confirm and verify the
Electoral you know votes right and so
when you have
someone like Tucker Carlson who's been
pushing since January 6 that Ashley
Babbitt Ashley Babbitt Ashley Babbitt
was the victim and Trump says she was
the victim and they all say who shot
Ashley Babbitt who killed Ashley Babbitt
I'm just asking questions she was
totally innocent she was the victim
right and when her mom gets arrested on
January 6th two years later to the day
they want to play the idea that Ashley
Babbitt's mom was a victim she was
innocent she was totally scared to be
arrested
when you hear them when you hear them
attack Paul Pelosi and basically
villainized Paul Pelosi
and and and and and and and in a way
they give the attacker this like well he
was only doing what he felt but here's
the thing that's why they conflate the
two right they conflate the two uh
falsely because
um to compare them is ridiculous it
would be it I mean the Ashley Babbitt
comparison to uh de shite or whatever
his [__] name is that went in and
bashed pelosian
the [__] and whatever this guy is
whoever this [__] mogla Knight is
this Q Anon Nut Job
um it would all it would be like Paul
Pelosi breaking into his house
to try to take away his rights and then
the [__] pounding him Paul Pelosi in
the head with a hammer because that's
what Ashley Babbitt did again the exact
opposite thing it's the same way as they
conflate January 6 with the the the
right the
um the the protest that that agitators
on on Trump's side turned into riots uh
in 2020 after the George Floyd murder uh
and they want to blame black lives
matter for a lot of the property damage
when it was agitators not not the
protesters not the the peaceful
protesters which we're going to see more
of that with this Tyree Nichols tape I'm
sure and there's going to be more of
this conflating January 6 with peaceful
protest when agitators turn a peaceful
protest into into property damage and
rioting because that's that's on the
table here it's it's part of what they
want and they're going to do it
intentionally but conflating these two
things is [__] ridiculous but that's
what that's what Tucker does now out you
sent me a link to this um
Pelosi footage do we have enough time to
watch some of this or or what or should
yeah it's only uh it's only two uh it's
less than two minutes but you can it's
basically the cut the the moment at
which it happens
um as this is as they're walking in from
the street this is the body this is the
the this is
that Tucker Carlson wanted to have well
this is the thing that they said if we
have this we'll know the truth right
and I'm sure he won't be asking any
questions yeah and gaslighting about
this video at all I mean if anything
here's a and you'll see there's a
hesitation between the more the point at
which they they open the door and they
talk to them and they Shine the Light
and then Paul Pelosi tries to like he's
like no no no don't and then you see him
swing and then they go in if anything
I could see Tucker Carlson saying well
why didn't they act sooner why didn't
they shoot him why didn't they protect
Paul Pelosi is there some sort of
underground hatred for the Pelosi family
I'm just asking questions I guarantee it
I guarant [__] to you he's gonna try
to spend any narrative he can to divert
from the truth in the first place
because the truth is here that he Tucker
Carlson has stoked stochastic terrorism
and he and his language and his
narrative and his messaging is a this is
the direct result of him pumping and
asking questions about Q Anon conspiracy
conspiracy theories as he likes to put
Eric I mean he put it in yeah
conspiracies right so you can scrub
through and you can go to the front door
when it all starts this is here right
yeah yeah right okay we'll bag it right
here yeah so this is right before they
open the door I'm assuming that the
police officers knocked a rang the
doorbell because they were called to
this residence for a disturbance
um I guess the the the reporting is and
that law enforcement has
um stated that Paul Pelosi made a phone
call to 9-1-1 at some point when this
[__] this manga [__] was in his
house this is the moment where the
police officers arrive at the front door
let's watch yeah
how you doing oh yeah what's going on
man
hi drop the hammer
hey hey hey what is going on right now
oh [__]
[Applause]
you're going to want to cut it off here
because that because after that then you
it's you see a little bit of the blood
and you hear Paul Pelosi like struggling
to breathe and well yeah because he was
just smashed in the head with a hammer
it's I mean it's the whole thing it's
[__] horrifying and yeah there is a
legitimate question like why didn't the
police you know [__] tase him or
something or do something quicker why
didn't they why did they wait for it to
happen there are some legitimate
questions but obviously you're going to
hear the right wing media
push that same angle
and say probably like oh SF Police are
not trained properly this and that all
this [__] and they're gonna push it
they're gonna push it they're gonna push
it and they're gonna say how it wasn't
and they're going to ignore the fact
they're gonna ignore the fact that he
was ever attacked and that all of their
conspiracies and their their ideas and
their narratives and their
misinformation that they spread before
was ever actually a possibility that
they ever even said like ah what I never
said that never did that never even
talked about it
and so then now they're gonna they're
gonna shift it and then place the blame
not on the actual attacker but they're
gonna shift the blame on the police and
then say why didn't the police to act
quicker why didn't they do something why
didn't they why didn't why didn't they
why didn't they do it why do you mean
yeah
you believe whatever you want to believe
and I'm going to ask the questions that
makes you and your and your your bias
believe what I want you to believe that
I know you believe anyways because I'm
the one who told you to believe what you
believe oh it's so funny how Tucker
Carlson is so mortified that the asset
police the San Francisco Police
Department would not release the body
cam footage because he would know the
truth and he was actually projecting to
his audience at that time of what would
be in the body cam footage so that way
when the body cam footage is released to
say the fact that he knows are [__]
true because law enforcement's saying it
and backing up and he doesn't need the
tape to believe them yeah and then and
he's basic basically what he did folks
and this is why we pulled the audible
and for Tucker Carlson to be the
dishonorable mention because it's
dishonorable
disgraceful and Despicable for [__]
[__] Tucker Carlson to intentionally
lead his audience to to automatically
take this video that he knows was going
to show what law enforcement said it
showed he knows that he knew that he
knew it and he he is stoking more
terrorism just like this by doing that
then so that way when this tape is
released they don't believe that that's
terrorism no it's not there must have
been something else must have been
something else
um which Speaking of something else
leads us to our Outback of the week and
I can think of a million reasons why
this guy is our Apple cook but I didn't
have a specific reason here right Elon
Musk ended up on her apple cook now
yesterday we got news that he met with
Hakeem Jeffrey worries he met with
Hakeem Jeffries to telekim Jeffries
apparently that he was going to treat
each political party with equal and fair
treatment on his platform but when he
met with Kevin McCarthy I think it was
just so he could tell Kevin McCarthy
happy birthday Kevin that's what Kevin
McCarthy said he didn't have any
discussions with him they're like why
was he here and then they're like oh he
makes me happy birthday no collusion he
just wished me a happy birthday it was a
perfect happy birthday it was perfect do
you see the pattern here
um no actually Elon Musk actually
tweeted out yesterday that he met with
Kevin McCarthy Anakin Jeffries I told
you I don't know what I don't remember
what day it was this week I said Elon
Musk is going to go before the [__]
House Republicans and he's going to do
exactly what they're claiming that the
government did with Twitter with the
Twitter file like he's gonna do the
exact thing that he's Elon and the
Republicans are accusing the Old Guard
at Twitter of doing but I think that's
why you put him on phone of the week
because of um some other stuff well also
hold on I'm getting this I I haven't
verified this but uh Sienna Ponders says
though musk said he also met with House
minority leader Hakeem Jeffries and Aid
to Jeffrey said he did not have a
scheduled meeting with the billionaire
but was introduced when they crossed
paths in McCarthy's office so even the
meeting itself down on the left side to
balance it out isn't a real thing well
it's surprise surprise surprise I I mean
you know again it's all projection even
from Elon it's always projection this is
what these people traffic in is [__]
information and Twitter files is just a
prime example of [__] information
they're taking they're taking uh
breadcrumbs of facts and twisting it
into the narrative that they want to
spend not the actual truth or giving
context to why those facts are the way
they are it's the same thing Trump did
we just watched the tape when he's like
the FBI paid Twitter three million
dollars to do work that they needed them
to do and and Twitter didn't expect to
do it for free I mean it's really stupid
we went over that yesterday yeah and
then in the tape with Trump because
because you know at the end of the day
for that one it's like if you were
someone Contracting work out to another
group you would pay them for the work
because they weren't able to do what
they normally do it's pretty pretty
standard business protocol to say I have
a job or a task can you fulfill it if so
I will pay you for that work so who is
this Ella Urban or Irwin so she's the
the head or you know she's the the house
yeah
and so there's a lot of stuff in this
article which I recommend reading but
basically the the tldr of this is that
while Elon pushes the idea that he's a
balanced approach right he's a mid he's
a person in the middle even though right
before the midterms he said for the
Republicans free he said yes he said
vote for Republicans before the midterms
the guy who has 120 million followers
decides hey the best thing I can do
right now as an independent uh
you know kind of Watcher of politics who
never even voted in the midterms right
is to tell other people to vote to tell
other people right and so not even a
certain person a certain party right he
goes I think it'll be better if we have
more Republicans and really really you
you think that wow but Dave Sanchez the
reason why is because he knows
Republicans are going to be on his side
and not want to hold him accountable
yeah totally they're going to want to
work with them on this disinformation
campaign than his Twitter files and I'm
guessing that this story about Ella here
is part of that disinformation profile
that the Republicans are really trying
to get Elon Musk to cooperate on because
we know and in your Tweet you say in
November Elon Musk ban uh activist Chad
loader from Twitter which was several
times like his account was on and off on
and off on and off
Chad goes by they them yeah yeah okay
yeah their account was on off on off on
off but then it also happened it also
happened after Chad had revealed there
was a there was a hack that happened and
a bunch of accounts had been leaked and
and Chad revealed that he posted or uh
they posted on on Twitter and right
after Chad was I think within a few days
or something Chad was was was suspended
right and then came back and suspended
again and then you know yeah it was on
offer like several weeks there right
um and you go on to say in Twitter's
internal system a noted quote suspension
direct request from Elon Musk and that's
towards Chad's
um suspension
um but at the same time you go on to say
Elon loves platforming right ring idiots
like cat Turk and Nazi Nick Fuentes now
Nick Fuentes his his re-uh his
re-establishment of his Twitter account
was short-lived yeah it was like 24
hours before he got suspended again
right but the other thing too in this
article they also talk about Jack
Sweeney Jack Sweeney is the is the
teenager who created Elon yet right
which was the service that tracked
elon's flight patterns based on someone
that he claimed that saturation attempts
and [__] which then we find out
later that there was nothing involved
with an assassination attempt this
person was not connected to Elon Musk or
or in terms of wanting to hurt him so
Elon made up a story about how this
person had tracked through Elon jet via
Twitter account found where he was going
to land thought he was there and then
attacked the driver and his son X in the
car but it turns out that was all fake
it wasn't real it was a made-up story
for Elon Musk to justify surely not to
uh to suspend or ban Elon Jet and they
actually they don't lie to us do they
yeah yeah yeah no they don't lie to us
so this Ella is uh is she is she she's
the head of trust and safety so she's
right now Elon simp is she an Elon oh
yeah yeah she's the one that's been
she's the one that's been helping uh
with the Twitter files she was also the
one I think that was in direct
connection with uh getting Elon Jet and
Jack Sweeney uh well great why not put a
liar in head of trust and safety yeah
why not why not why not why not do the
exact opposite of what the department is
is trust and safety put someone that you
can't trust and it's not safe that's
perfect I mean why wouldn't we put
someone in who just completely throws
out trust and safety [__] out the
window and then also torches it and says
I am the captain now you know it's like
it honestly is this moment where
where Republicans want to claim that oh
man we're we're being persecuted we're
being oppressed and we're being our
voices were being suppressed on this
platform and and Jack and and all these
other people were doing it and then you
find out that now because there's no and
here's the other thing
there was a there was a team in place
right that if Executives made a decision
that team would then check the
executives to say uh we shouldn't do
this right there's a check in Balance
they're almost like
they had created kind of a democratic
system where they said if someone whoa
whoa whoa whoa easy on the Democracy
here
okay I'll just call it generation yeah
so there's so they had this dematria
system okay they had this democratic
system that basically said if an
executive level person or group makes a
decision
then another group there's an oversight
committee that says uh you know what
we're gonna we're gonna check you on
that and you're gonna have to confirm
and and make your case make your case to
why we should actually go through this
sounds this sounds this sounds very
suspicious because it almost sounds like
not authoritarian and that would be a
very difficult system for someone like
Elon Musk to live in so when you abandon
when when you totally ditch and abandon
any of the moderation the team that was
you know was monitoring and the
oversight oversight ethics uh you get
rid of the guy that had Joel who is the
head of trust and safety who had
expressed concerns as well as his team
around the blue check mark scam that was
going to happen they anticipated this
stuff you mean that's still scamming but
the idea that they had anticipated this
stuff because I don't know they're
[__] professionals or it was
experience it was obviously it was
obvious and nothing they were doing was
illegal and the Twitter files only show
that but they want to find some oh my
God this is wrong and look what they did
and they were totally trying to attack
you yes deep deep State deep state so
you have you have this right now and it
just shows you that Elon Musk again
despite what he says helping out
captured helping out Nazi Nick Fuente I
can't even believe we have to say that
helping out pattern now here's my
question has kind of turned on him
oh well yeah of course because cat turd
is not [__] Tethered to reality so
well catrard also doesn't understand how
the algorithm works
well that's what I'm saying is he's not
Tethered to reality here right and
that's what pisses him off is because
his reality is something that's
completely not reality and it and it
hurts you uh in in um your quest for the
truth and what is real but here's the
thing here's my prediction and this is a
really far-fetched prediction but is it
hell what might not be because I I want
to transition to our bonehead winner
here but my guess is is that if Ella
doesn't work out which I'm sure she
won't work out in trust and safety
seeing that she's such a [__] liar
I would bet Elon Musk might find a
better liar than even Ella I bet he
could find a really good lighter if and
only if this person decides to resign
their position as New York third's
congressperson which is representative
George Santos because let's face it this
guy is just an average Republican but he
loves every single Republican line that
he can get his hands on like everything
yeah one of them this week was oh boy I
mean if there was if if if there was
ever a moment what was it what was it
again what was this week
you said
good boy oh boy if you can describe if
you could describe George Santos this
week this week oh boy
it really it really was a moment where
where you you had you had to you know it
is crazy that we have to have these you
know these conversations but you you
kind of say this out loud to yourself
you're like wow if there was ever a
moment of all the things that George
Santos has done that have been
questionable illegal Shady whatever he
decides when he's under the most amount
of [__] Spotlight Limelight you know
he's out there giving Chick-fil-A which
is an anti-lgbtq pro-christian group
right that makes food
but he's lgbtq you know he's giving out
cupcakes that no one should ever touch
with a [__] 10-foot pole his surprise
was I think just the snacks that he had
given people the donuts
I think the surprise is is that he would
be surprised if he actually ate the [__]
that he put on the table right right and
so the idea because you ate it right and
you you would you would think you would
think and I honestly think there was
something wrong like like
psychologically with George Santos
because gape gape gape he's a republican
yeah I know but you would you would have
to assume that if a republican was under
an intense amount of Spotlight and you
had reporters outside your door chasing
you through the capitol every single day
from the elevator to your office from
your office to the elevator to the
garage outside everywhere around you
would think that maybe Republican maybe
a republican would say ah I should
probably just like
ease the [__] brakes right now not
hold on and not do anything that's crazy
because I got a lot of people looking at
me right now right and I and I would say
that Republicans in in some regard are a
little bit smarter that they would go
you know what I did some shady stuff and
I can probably excuse the past but if I
do it right now I don't have a good
excuse so I probably want to at least
for the moment ease off the brakes don't
do anything crazy or illegal
but with with George Santos he goes well
why not double down well why not check
it in again Gabe Sanchez
your good friend you're the co-host the
executive producer here but I've been
telling you this since the day we met
George Santos in in the universe of
commentary and the political body in the
political space George Santos
is not the original Santos no no no no
no no not at all Donald Trump is the OG
Santos and he's only following the
trumpism model here he's only following
because I will agree that is true
because your audience that other
Republicans would probably pump the
brakes at least for a moment
but then we found out this week that he
was like nah and then did something that
was like oh that's definitely illegal so
George Santos ended up being the bone of
the week you vote and you decided and of
course you decided that George Santos
would be our bone Hen of the week it was
pretty much even on both Twitter and
YouTube it was like the same 55 on both
right so he got 55 on both poles right
is that what you're saying okay yeah
yeah
um
there are so many stories this week
about George Santos that put him on the
bone of the week but I think the one
that uh you put him on here specifically
is the um I don't like the campaign
Finance crimes and he's kind of
admitting to
um and that he not only is admitting to
but he's doing like right out in the
open right so tell us give us a rundown
of why
because I know you got another story you
talked about it earlier it's kind of in
the back pocket we're still confirming
some things still confirming and I want
you to tell us as much as you can about
that but tell us first about and give us
the uh the rundown of this uh because
there's a clip of him um saying
something too right I'll try to find why
you're why you're giving the rundown
yeah so the the the quick the quick and
dirty of this is there are two kind of
financially related aspects that that uh
Santos doubled down on this week right
or or confirmed
so before I mean you can even go back
there's a clip of George Santos talking
to Matt Gates on the war room while
Steve Bannon was on assignment AKA he
was in court for his uh we build the
wall scam oh is this the one where he
and Matt gets asked him where the money
came from yeah he goes and I can tell
you where it didn't come from exactly he
goes it didn't come from this or Ukraine
or or this or whatever and he's like
well that's an answer but what preceded
it was you know
a lot of people have don't you know a
lot of people have been to question
where your money came from and I've
personally donated my own money you know
on my campaign this is Matt Gates he's
like I personally know I've done when
I've done charity work I make sure to
contribute to my own Charities and
things like I have my own money and I
know that you personally loaned your
campaign seven hundred thousand dollars
and he goes uh-huh yeah yeah and
confirms it and then he asked him you
know where it came from so I think so
let's let's watch this let's watch this
where he asked him where it came from
work you did that was the origin of
those resources look I've worked my
entire life I've lived an honest life
I've never been a accused shoot of any
bad doing so you know it's it's my it's
the equity of my hard working itself and
I've invested inside of me like I said
didn't come from barisma it didn't come
for Ukraine Russia China uh unlike some
folks that we all know that get money
from those sources
Trump has to be totally jealous though
oh yeah that's not the clip that's not
the clip there's a clip that's right
before it because he's right now right
so right like this this is the follow-up
of him saying yes I did he confirming
yes I did give my money to the campaign
and Matt gant's question was well where
did this money come from right and he's
like well I'll tell you what David
that's the question and you know where
else it didn't come from George Santos
because he did not give the personal
loan money yeah well are you telling me
that the Scandal this week is that
George Santos lied about a lie about
another lie that he did and now my guess
is my guess is that he did something
corrupt and criminal to try to cover up
the LIE off top of the lie on top of the
line am I right am I right yes yep okay
so what happened here so then they went
in and they tried to uh amend
ment
they try to amend the financial filings
that they have for the campaign filings
which sometimes is a regular thing yeah
yeah totally fine it's a thing they
should do if they find a discrepancy
they should amend it right right but
when you're talking about the amount of
500 000
that's a big Amendment right and and his
financials are already under scrutiny
because he filed a lot of expenses for
199.99 which is under the 200 Mark that
you're supposed to be reporting this
stuff so it's unusual that all of these
amounts equaled out to exactly 199.99
it's almost as suspicious As Trump
charging 99 for digital trading cards
and then saying you can only buy 100
which means that you now have to pay
you know under the ten thousand dollar
mark
for these digital trading cards which is
right under the nine you know nine
thousand nine hundred ninety nine under
the what is required to file and report
to the IRS
so it's just as suspicious again just
like OG
yeah that's weird that's suspicious but
it's the same thing so then when you
have George Santos saying you know
anywhere from 500 to 625 to 700 000 as
personal loan was done from him which by
the way we know
all of the lies of of Santos being like
Oh yeah I was a landlord and I owned
like 11 properties and I did this and
this and this and I worked for uh uh
Goldman Sachs and Citibank and then all
of this stuff is a complete lie the guy
was was almost was broke almost all the
time he lived in an apartment with his
mom his sister and then also other
people there's there's new accounts of
former roommates being like Oh yeah we
cycled in and out of that apartment
while we were living together and it was
a complete mess it was chaos
um in New York and so this week they
were like oh actually we're gonna we're
gonna amend the filing and then and then
it said you know and so another amended
filing said that disclosed at 125 000
from the alone from the candidate in
late October also did not come from
personal funds but like the 500 000 in
questions he did not say where the money
came from right when the loan was due or
what the entity who backed it or where
it came from at all that was what
happened this week
and then
we find out that George Santos I mean it
committed fraud I mean it's foreign wait
did you're telling me because I'm almost
guessing yeah that because this clip
here let's play this clip here where he
says I don't touch my violence right
here and then we'll see if
that's a lie I I'm guessing I'm just
gonna make guess but let's watch
Clifford I mean you can always just
assume it's always
right so don't be disingenuous and
report that I did because you know that
every campaign hires Judiciary so I'm
not aware of that answer and we'll have
an answer for the Press regarding the
Amendments and yes okay so he's saying
he's saying my FCC filings normally what
you do is you hire like an accountant a
fiduciary to to do that work for you so
it doesn't look like you're doing it on
your own it's someone who's separate
from you yeah a third party yeah right
and maybe maybe George Santos uh said he
did hire someone and maybe he put their
name on that iron I bet what you're
going to tell me though I I almost bet
what you're gonna tell me is that he's a
[__] liar in this clip is that what
you're gonna tell me he's a [__] oh
yeah 100 because what we then found out
oh my God was that he sent a letter okay
this the letter uh from Santos uh on his
paper the fiduciary yeah yeah it it
basically the guy that they hired the
guy that they hired they hired right
right uh Thomas Detweiler right they
claimed was their new Treasurer and
custodian of Records the fiduciary yeah
yeah simple terms fiduciary I'm just
trying to spell it out
so basically what happened was people
started asking questions they say where
you know where are these amendments why
why are you amending it's a lot of money
what happened what happened what
happened right because the week started
January 23rd right uh the the money
story came out January 24th so that was
Tuesday that it came out that these
loans weren't personal they came from
somewhere else and he wouldn't tell us
where
I know I look weird but I'm just waiting
to be surprised which I'm not yeah yeah
so that's so that's that's Tuesday so
the week starts Monday after he had just
been dragged the previous week
and then Tuesday comes around and we
find out oh this money wasn't actually
from personal uh personal loans uh
himself and then Wednesday yeah we find
out that in an attempt to like scurry
and [__] cover up the lie with
another lie yeah what happens is he says
uh oh actually I do have someone who's
handling the fiduciary responsibilities
of right campaign his name is Thomas
Detweiler that's great that's great he's
a new Treasurer in the custodian records
so that's one it's one thing to say like
this is the person right however uh oh
I'm saying I bet you're gonna say
Thursday there's something else happened
here well yeah but it's still part of
Wednesday but we'll call it Thursday
basically revealed
that signature by Detweiler right to say
like hey FEC we're you know we're
amazing new fiduciary the new producer
that he's giving a clip all of my all of
my uh my my role my responsibilities as
fiduciary person right right except we
find out that George Santos actually
forged detwiler's signature on the
forums claiming that he was meanwhile
detwiler's like uh I I don't know I
don't work with him and I would not work
with him well you know what and I don't
know how this he might have been like I
didn't work with George Santos I was
working with Andy devolder right now
Anthony zabrovski you're right
I was talking on the phone with Anthony
zabronski and his assistant Anthony
devolder I was right yeah communication
directly oh my God so George Santos in a
week has you know it's been revealed
he's amended he's he's amended these
Financial dollars how how how
is anyone surprised that he is the
member of the Republican party and he is
the he is the vote that delivered us
Kevin McCarthy's speaker how is anyone
surprised about and and he is the reason
why they changed the entire Ethics
Committee so he can stay in congress
because that was probably the promise
right Kevin McCarthy made him win he got
his vote I mean when when they were like
oh yeah we're gonna basically uh we're
just gonna totally gut this Ethics
Committee he was like fantastic
literally he said fantastic that sounds
awesome I'm totally for it I'm totally
for it we don't need to have these right
bureaucracies of people looking over my
shoulder who wants to make sure members
of Congress are ethical who would want
to make sure of that and and also the
fact that he's on the small business
committee
is well I mean it is very
entrepreneurial of him Jamie uh come up
with this fiduciary out of thin air here
I mean you know I mean George George
scam toast you know or I mean I just put
dollar signs in the s's on the scam
turian candidate the scam sharing
candidate candidate George Santos oh my
God and I guarantee next week we're
gonna find even more because we have to
also realize that George Santos is not
gonna resign he will never resign if you
continue I mean like just the fact that
he lied the way that he did this week I
mean he's gonna go to [__] he's
[__] so [__] so absolutely [__]
he's not he's not you know everyone
keeps saying he's going to get
extradited Brazil I'm like he's not even
gonna get a chance to get extra right
now Brazil he's not at all like the
other stuff in the past when you're like
oh he lied about this and he lied about
his mom dying in the Twin Towers and he
you know he lied about not doing drag
these were all like I mean they're
terrible things to lie about you know in
the grand scheme like your grandparents
surviving the Holocaust but they really
were in Brazil during the whole time and
they're Catholic the whole thing you're
like ah those are that's like a real
shitty human thing to do like you
wouldn't lie about those things
but when then you when you start what if
you're a republican
wouldn't you I mean come on man yeah I
mean yeah but it's your typical
Republican line I mean Donald Trump
total lie about 9 11 too that's why I
keep saying he's the ogc remember he's
like right oh we watched his people
across where cheery Muslims were
cheering like that's not what it's like
I went down to the Twin Towers that day
didn't go down there I I knew I knew
people who who died I he didn't need to
know anything it was all [__] lies it
was all lies and he was playing at the
heartstrings of people who were affected
by 9 11 just like George Santos was
that's the thing I keep telling I keep
telling he's the OG Trump is the OG
Santos Santos is just following the
model he's just really shitty-headed
because he's stupid now he's like he's
like uh he's like a trump Padawan right
right right Trump is a I mean Jedi
obviously you have to be very still
but you know uh he's kind of like a
paddle like he's a he's a he's a Trumper
in training you know okay yeah he's got
his like Trump or training pants on
would that be it would that be a diaper
or does it depend no well I mean I guess
it depends on what state you're in it
depends it depends okay so we know this
fraud here it's been exposed um George
Santos is going to be in a shitload of
trouble over this fraud but there is
another fraud I think that we're that
you are looking into uh yeah and you
don't have all the details because we
haven't confirmed everything yeah this
thing so what can you tell us about a
fraud that uh happened before he was
a congressman what can you tell us about
this that we're going to try to get this
out in the open yeah
um and there's there's a other there's
I'll just say this I won't be the I
won't be the only one to report on this
right I might have to there might there
might be details that I can't get so
I'll have to release the video after I
get the full story but basically
uh I spoke with the person who
um who was in The Animal Rescue
um
industry so this has to do with his dog
cheers so yeah and so if everyone if
everyone remembers or if anyone
remembers the patch story that uh
Jacqueline sweet wrote um who I also
connected with the other day and I I
chatted with her and she uh super
helpful and gave me some resources but
she's actually been digging it I mean
she was like look George Santos is it's
like a rabbit hole once you start going
down One path it's not always going to
be oh this is the clear answer because
then what ends up happening is you
realize that there's now like Forks in
the so you're saying tunnels you're
saying there's a pattern to his lying is
that what you're saying there's a
pattern to his line I mean there's a ton
of Lies there's a new one that just came
out that revealed he was spreading uh he
was sending messages that were
pro-hitler right uh oh yeah I've seen
this one yesterday yeah yeah so all all
the while saying he was Jewish right
right
and he's like ish you know even though
he's Catholic and his grandparents are
from Brazil Hitler which is yeah yeah
and that also comes out after you know
and then he responded to that last night
playing victim by saying oh they're
coming at me it's a smear campaign and
all this [__] and they're just
making up lies these aren't lies these
are actual posts and I've seen
screenshots I've seen it I think it's
like both Facebook comment sections
right where you see yeah yeah and that's
where they're getting him right because
and I I know I have his Facebook uh
and I and I know where he is and and in
the sense that I also have other stuff
in terms of contact him which I may I
may do to verify certain certain
pieces of information about this other
fraud maybe yeah so tell us about what
you know back to this so it all goes
back to the dog right the we we revealed
that George Santos scammed this one
veteran Richard osthoff for three
thousand dollars by saying he was going
to help raise the money
and then when Richard was like great we
raised the money to remove the tumor and
the growth that's on my dog uh Sapphire
George Santo goes oh you got to go here
and you can't transport with them and
this and that he's like all making all
these hoops that he had to go through
and it took so long that the growth had
um had grown four or five times the size
and it was too big to removed and he had
to unfortunately and sadly put his dog
down euthanize his dog Sapphire George
Santos killed the veterans dog there's
actually a there's good news that also
comes out of it now
Howard Stern
talked about it on his show yeah and
Howard Stern's wife then connected and
basically made these connections so that
uh Richard could help get another
support animal so now he's going to get
a new support dog uh to to help him
because right now he's got two personal
dogs but he doesn't have a support dog I
think is what I read and it's all
because of uh Howard Stern talking about
on the radio and covering the story
because again Howard Stern New Yorker
talking about this stuff covering the
news
um and trying to help this veteran out
and now he's working with another
organization to get a new dog but
the reason when you bring up there's a
pattern there is absolutely a pattern
and all I can say is that this is not
the first time that George Santos has
pulled this type of scam on someone
when it comes to dog rescues and the way
in which he ran this quote-unquote which
I have not been able to find he called
it a you know rescue was a non-profit
myself there's no filing yeah and the
reporters who have worked on this have
not been able to actually find any
actual uh
okay okay okay so I again I go back to
the OG Santos uh I mean we know now that
the the election fund thing was not a
real thing there was no filing of it
um Trump and his family have stole money
from from pet Charities before I mean
this
it really does feel like Santos is the
is the the the Trump and training here
but he really he's not missing the mark
by
um by doing all the frauds and all the
scams and all I'm just I just can't wait
to hear this story about what pattern
that um George Santos is lying about so
that we can expose it so that the world
can see it
um not that Republicans are Kevin
McCarthy or the Ethics Committee will do
anything about it because it doesn't
exist anymore because uh Kevin
McCarthy's soul is sold to the OG Santos
and George Santos
but Gabe Sanchez this is not a surprise
that our audience voted
for George Santos as the bonehead of the
week so
in true fashion here on bonehead leak
let's once again four out of five times
four out of five times George Santos
is four out of five on bone out of the
week let's give him his dude
[Music]
[Applause]
oh Santos the scam turian candidate now
you are a [__] bonehead uh everyone
every single Friday we do bonehead of
the week here on the Tony Michaels
podcast and we post a clip on Midas
Touch Network don't forget to subscribe
to the Tony Michaels podcast on YouTube
and if you're on Midas that's watching
the clip right now make sure to
subscribe on our channel the Tony
Michaels podcast on YouTube and the
minus touch Network also you can vote
for bonetta week on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod and on the YouTube channel
so don't forget to subscribe have I said
it three times yet to subscribe to the
YouTube subscribe subscribe subscribe go
to the community tab you'll be able to
vote on the community tab for bone of
the week every single week and on
Twitter and also download every single
episode of our podcast and don't forget
to watch live every single weekday
Monday through Friday noon Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific for two full hours
where in the second hour of Friday we do
bone end of the week uh George Santos
boy you've given us a lot of bonehead
content because you are a [__]
bonehead
everybody this has been your edition of
the scam turian candidate bonehead of
the week
[Music]
[Applause]
of the week
I meant to after I said after I said
scam turian candidate last week I was
like oh I've got the graphic ready to go
and then uh I I forgot to finish it so
today I will do this from my comment
last week and I was like oh we'll call
him scammatory in Canada I meant to
share it so I'll share it today okay
good on Twitter yeah share it on Twitter
and we'll spread it around the scam
chart I'm gonna use the original the OG
I think I'm gonna use the OG poster from
the movie okay okay that's good you mean
you mean the OG movie because yo you're
a hard poster yeah right because there's
two main injury and candidate movies
right right right right and in the
original I think I believe Frank Sinatra
played The Manchurian Candidate didn't
he in the original am I wrong on things
so are you sure are you sure
[Music]
wasn't the original oh no Frank Sinatra
yeah God damn I'm good God damn I'm good
I know a little bit of movie He plays
Major oh major Bennett Marco no no no no
he's not oh he snapped them Raymond
Raymond Shaw I believe but Frank Sinatra
is in the movie yeah yeah he's in the
movie yeah
Shaw is the sleeper agent and Frank
Sinatra plays the major in that well
maybe I just I felt Santos inside of me
so I lied him yeah yeah just a little
don't don't disrespect Sinatra like this
little life just little lies here and
there a little bit of fraud a little bit
of you know campaign Finance violations
Federal violation you know just little
stuff little stuff
um that these Republicans do like George
Santos he was just
again just an average Republican and we
will drag them we will mock them here on
the Tony Michaels podcast so don't
forget to tune in every single weekday
noon Eastern 11 Central on YouTube
subscribe to YouTube right now do not
forget to do that and follow us on
Twitter at Tony Michaels pod download it
at every single directory everywhere and
if you're on Facebook right now follow
us at the Tony Michaels also on Twitch
twitch is free why not why not grab the
Twitch app hey grab the Twitch app why
not why not watch us there too
we appreciate the audience out there and
again I want to give one last shout out
before the weekend to all the people who
have
um went over to my patreon and supported
me and I think you're setting one up too
right yeah yeah I'm gonna set one up
yeah good good um and that way people
can probably I'm going to work on it
this weekend and I will it'll be you
know it's important what was that
exactly yeah yeah we will probably we'll
probably have it ready to go on Monday
to announce you're working really hard
on the what was that content uh you want
you're wanting to do some new things uh
with it so anyone who watches and loves
the what was that
um piece of content be looking for
Gabe's in that new patreon for what was
that specifically
um to do more and more of that kind of
content
um and we will try to promote of course
we do here promote the what was that
content
um but so be stay tuned we'll give you
those links you'll get the linky links
you get those links
right but I want to give a shout out to
everyone everyone who has um joined my
patreon and then again uh for those
people who get a special shout out I'm
still working on exactly how I'm going
to do that
um I've got some ideas but I'm going to
come up with some stuff over the weekend
and we'll do something next week to give
everyone who has joined the 20 tier on
my patreon a proper shout out uh for you
guys I'm not sure exactly I'm gonna do
it but I'm I'm getting some ideas I'm
collecting some things so we'll do that
everyone have a shape weekend be safe be
vigilant out there I'm telling you this
um this tape of the murder of Tyree
Nichols is going to um
arouse feelings in this country and um
there's going to be surely some peaceful
protest
um but be vigilant and um also no
justice no peace and uh you you moderate
white people out there you need to
understand don't be complicit in this um
in this situation because there's going
to be a narrative that is going to
happen over the next six months eight
months of this country over this video I
think
um also I I did post the uh I did tweet
out the Paul Pelosi video we didn't show
the whole thing here but you can go
watch the whole thing in that clip I
tweeted it out so you can check that
video out and I as soon as I can get
some clips of the uh Tyree Nichols
whatever is allowed to be posted on
social media I will be I will be
retweeting on Twitter I definitely
believe that you have to go watch it you
cannot be comfortable you cannot you
cannot have peace you have to watch this
video you have to know what happened it
is super important because again in the
Birmingham letter from the Birmingham
Jail of Martin Luther King and the black
lives matter movement after George Floyd
was murdered and every single man and
woman who is murdered by police officers
in this country no justice no peace have
a safe weekend we will see you same time
same place on Monday surfs that
[__] you've been listening to
the Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon